- lucky you you happen to be watching
the best show that has ever existed
anywhere - three podcasts thank you for
watching thank you for being here thank
you to my beautiful co-host ela climb
the the swag master got a new haircut
looking fantastic your hair looks
amazing you look amazing hurt it's
Maybelline what are those
what or the commercials back in the day
where they was these shampoo that was so
good it sounds like they were like
zooming ah I'll have what she's having
that's you is YouTube gonna deem on me
cuz I said orgasm yep there they are
that sensitive I'm dead serious
I'm bi just constantly at war with
YouTube I do - our podcasts it's
impossible that I don't say something
edgy like orgasm god forbid it's not my
why you come here look was such bomb
hair like I'm not gonna say orgasm the
thirst for 30 seconds to get her a whole
episode monetize you're coming out with
this bomb ass hair now I'm talking about
Maybelline dear fault because Herbal
Essences Herbal Essence I did like
Herbal Essence what about horrible life
related the the multi-level lighting
company they're huge they're like
they've sponsor soccer teams I was
surprised to see that like team
Herbalife I was like do you guys know
that they're like just like logging yeah
don't sue me Herbalife they have a lot
of money allegedly it's blood money this
is a parody so when I say scam then when
I say that Herbalife is a scam and a
fraud and blood money I'm saying that as
a parody it's a joke
I'm a comedian after all guys we've got
a lot to talk about here today as you
could see in the title and the thumbnail
it's all happening
everything at once but before we get to
the headlines I do want to mention my
feeding window wait do you want to thank
the sponsors oh [ __ ] hems and quit
thank you to hems and quit for
sponsoring this episode of the h3
podcast thank you for reminding me thank
you thank you do you know what a feeding
window is let's talk about that so I I'm
just I'm on like a runaway train of
fatness right now I'm just getting
fatter and fatter we were at a wedding
yeah weekend jaunt Ron's wedding which
was beautiful and glorious I'm very
happy for him Haman isn't in his new
bride Dan you're screaming sponsors but
I'm assuming about the old
congratulations to Dan and his new wife
Charlotte beautiful what did I say today
you guys oh my god what is wrong with me
no I've been eating a lot I always eat a
lot no I think it's because we just
moved there's a lot going on Lois okay
I'll help you stay on track we got to
talk about the wedding so that we can
talk about the fitting window so the
wedding was beautiful it was it was
gorgeous it was nice seeing all the
youtubers there I saw i dub light ups
and his a wonderful girlfriend and he
saw hmm
I even saw Jason aka dunkey yeah and
Leah there which was long gone newlywed
right there's a lot of love in the air
yeah and I was just I turned around I
was like Jason Elliott they didn't say
hi to me and I was like maybe they
didn't see me but I was like what and we
spent the majority of the night with
hanging out with them that was a joy
Sh'ma yo I mean hello friend ler Michael
Gregory flew in from New York City the
donkey
the dunks that's how I refer to the and
Jaison fluent from Wisconsin that's some
real friendship yeah I just drove an
hour yeah so very cool people in Israel
complain when they have to drive an hour
to our wedding yeah people that I ask a
lot for weddings aren't they not ask a
lot but like people like yeah I'm having
a wedding in a the southern tip of Chile
I expect you all to come and pay for
your accommodation and there is a dress
code of like this very specific green
suit right you have to cost ten thousand
dollars and you'll need to wear to
attend I had a friend who invited me to
a wedding and Florida that was black tux
only I was like bro can you say uh I'm
not coming in a different way we're a
super broke that wasn't what was
happening in New York
and so you HOT it does it come with a
budget like no yeah who make it happen
he was a rich he was a very from a
wealthy family
and a lot of my other broke friends who
went there I was like boy I'm not
spending like five thousand dollars to
go to this guy's wedding but I feel like
um it's kind of cool you know because
people live here so far from each other
because it's so base but no it's kind of
cool that people actually will do it for
you I agree that's why they get the best
friend award but I'm not I'm not doing
that [ __ ]
who would I do that for is there anybody
I was put on the bucks and fly to
Florida for I think it's just a matter
of if you can afford it I mean we really
couldn't afford it but it's also now
that I can't afford it is there's a time
restraint like I'm not yeah but if if I
John's the wedding wasn't here it was in
Florida with a black tux only we would
have done it there's a good chance I
would have done it thank you what are
you talking about I'm just saying that's
asking a lot yeah are one of our good
friends his his he's not a rich guy he's
an ordinary everyday Joe they were
having a bat it wasn't even the wedding
the bachelor party was in like Cuba
they're like will you come down to Cuba
and get Zika virus
and he just had like a newborn babies
like I'm gonna get my kids Iike virus to
go party in Cuba like what are we gonna
be doing go through that right no he
didn't go cuz the doctor said you're
gonna get Zika and you have a new baby
yeah that's fine
but he didn't want ya so he didn't want
to go but the doctor gave him an out but
he's like I have to go it's my cousin I
was like bro I tell your cousin it's
[ __ ] oh no I'm not doing that
it's too much and I agree with you but
it's also kind of cool I have love and
appreciation for the people who saddle
up and do it that being said I don't
think that I'm one of those people I
think you are and you don't know it okay
I'll accept that because I feel like
that speaks volumes to someone's
character that they're willing to do
that I don't think I would be willing to
do that but the fact that you're gonna
give me the credit without having done
it
I accept okay thank you you're welcome
I'm having a wedding in a in the
southern pole of Antarctica would you
will you be attending I expect you to be
attending
you'll need a tote you'll need a
expedition guide a licensed expedition
guide and an oxygen mask hike that
wasn't fade up you'll need a guard to
fend off polar bears sure I'll make it
RSVP yes would you like would you like
whale blubber or walrus steak art Antico
wildlife got it
yeah we're having a wedding in the
center of the Amazon rainforest so can
we get to the fear at the aboriginal
tribe you'll need to be you'll need
shots against malaria
hepatitis F it's a new one that they
just discovered there you will need to
divorce your wife because you literally
cannot go back home to live like you're
used to you cannot be be you can't be
reintroduced to society unfortunately
after quarantine for six months and
we just have a little ask I do recommend
that you get your will and a state in
order before journey back to our wedding
and the center Amazon yeah yeah I'll
make that course how could I say no
anyway that brings me to the feeding
window so okay yeah the feeding window
we haven't gotten there yet so there was
a week well I started weeks before the
wedding telling Ethan you you have
nothing to wear because you do not fit
through your clothing
unfortunately no you need to buy and you
wouldn't do it and I was getting nervous
I could see ourselves like day of the
wedding and you don't know what to wear
so I had to buy your clothes oh and all
right that you would fit and then we
went to buy a shirt and we were like
okay let's get extra large because you
used to be large so you try on the large
Dan will you go I tweeted it to jontron
can you find that tweet the courrier you
tried on the extra-large yeah yeah well
show picture that but the clothing we
ordered online the pants was an elastic
waist dress pants which was so dope I
didn't hear welcoming and aisle I was
like whoa and Anila first was like you
can't talk into an elastic waist is
insane
I was like you know what I'm talking and
I talked and it looked pretty good yeah
I had no problem with that um here oh
that was quick thank you
here's what the extra large looked like
on me I took a picture because we were
those but those are those buttons are
fighting for life so the extra-large was
pretty long so we're like it looks so
funny on the back of like a dress super
tight dress yeah I wish we got the
replies okay well we had to get another
size that was even longer so it's like
down to my knees so
eels like you can't talk on the elastic
waist but the shirt looks like a skirt
when I'm like I'm talking in it anyway
so we found out that your to excel
well when yeah I mean well on a dress
shirt like that yeah I remember when you
were a medium I know that's a it's a
long lifetime ago and that's like three
sizes ago but okay let's continue with
the story what's where does it go from
here um so we are at the wedding
ya know we saw our friend Zach yeah oh
the feeding window the feeding window
yeah
so the feeding window Zach was starting
telling me I mean I know about
intermittent fasting but Zach goes I've
lost eight weights l88 eight weights God
what is wrong with me stop and think
before they like say every single word
eight pounds bus just by doing
intermittent fasting he gives himself a
eight hour feeding window and so mine
because I usually breakfast at 10:00 and
have dinner around 5:00 so my eight hour
feeding window is from 10:00 to 6:00 so
that means that I can eat anything I
want within that eight hour feeding
window and then the rest of the day is a
fast which lowers your insulin lowers
our speeds up your metabolism and you
are just burning calories during that
outside that feeding window I just like
saying feeding what I mean if you see
some of the farm animal
get me my crop maybe it's my feeding
window shoving your face it's my feeling
with the food heels are you sure you
want to eat up third hamburger today
they work good well here's where it
works I think I'm gonna try it you don't
know that it doesn't work you know that
for a fact
how do I get this says [ __ ] a
feeding window ya know here's why it
works besides that it lowers the
incident Co the reason it work
it's a mind game you set these rules for
yourself so you say okay I'm only gonna
eat between ten and six I'm a fast the
rest of the day you jaw you end up
eating less cow yeah you starve exactly
that's how long how long are you gonna
last a week I think I can live on two
meals a day that's not that crazy a lot
of people do that so why do you need the
window why not do a he'll give yourself
rules and yes stick to them and maybe I
want three hamburgers during I win what
however I don't eat three hamburgers as
a rule that's too specific overall
however I don't eat french fries period
that's too specific of rule what do you
want me to keep like 100 rules I'll make
rules for you yeah I want one rule I can
run rule to live by to rule your world
like the one ring that rules them all
the fede window from 10 a.m. to 6 p.m.
thou shalt not eat food outside the
feeding window you're gonna end up
wearing 3 XL by then this is feeding
hours not if I stick to the fast you
said it yourself I'll be starving it's
so bad for you and then you'll be eating
eating eating and that's what there's
that Zack said he's not for a week Zack
says it's good it's healthy too fast
it's good to have your insulin low
during those hours especially someone
like me who's on the verge of being a
diabetic free psychic pebbles yes the
nutritionists yeah you know you know any
stupid thing that someone will tell you
you'll pick up except the actual good
thing healthy living a lot of it you
need to change your home well like rain
Florence no I sound like a normal person
that doesn't have a feeding window
let's see what happens we'll give it a
week okay we'll check I'm gonna stick to
the viewing window I'm gonna stick and
then today what's today Tuesday next
Tuesday let's check in and let's see how
what's my status I'll get away myself
tonight
mm-hmm which I'm frankly and not looking
forward it's gonna be brutal okay and
both taken the feeding window
extravaganza I'm all right
do you guys have any weight loss tips
for me yeah work out anyone possible
that doesn't make sense damn I lost 70
pounds on Kido 70 yeah I used to weigh
almost 300 pounds really
you were you were like a pretty big dude
yeah huh yeah how's the big boy just
Kido like tell me about that Kido uh
it's the high fat no carbs no sugar diet
and so what were you eating on a daily
basis uh hamburger patties just a bunch
of protein and just a nice yeah cheese
that sounds so unhealthy right and that
work it just did
hamburger patties and cheese and you
lost seven - yeah it's just without the
bread I mean you're good and you just
don't eat the bread and lose 70 pounds
over what course period of time I lost
70 pounds in the span of six months whoa
yeah that's a lot I have a picture when
I was like can't we see yeah yeah sure
how do I listen to this sack not the
other Zac how do I see that picture well
work on that Tim we're gonna get there
and in the meantime right yeah Brad
we're - you definitely got a cutout of
bread not during the feeding window
anything goes during the feeding window
like today after you ate your breakfast
you started snacking on bread mm-hmm
because it's the fading Windom eight
hours to go crazy baby what if I combine
Kido with feet and oh yeah
then we're really onto something special
try it
mm-hmm all right what else we got God
smite before we get into the good stuff
well this is the good stuff frankly
there's a drummer that God there at a
church and he's drumming his heart out
first to my point he's in a little box
which oh I mean I never seen such a
thing it seems a little ridiculous
I guess it's to make the drums less loud
but I mean just let it rip dude you're
playing rock and roll you know Zach what
do you think about the drum box the drum
box yeah well it's not that I mean it's
not the craziest thing that sometimes
they will put like a glass thing in
front of a drum kit just to reduce noise
especially a nook is small yeah then you
like that it makes sense because the
drums will just overpower everything
else yeah so must be loud as hell in
that little cube probably it's like
being at a gun range in there well
anyway God wasn't down with this tooth
drumming because it's just neat well let
you see for yourself that God just
dropped the cross right on this dude
like da bro
[Music]
gods like ah [ __ ] this man boom dude he
got taken out that's like a heavy cross
have you heavy falls to the cross you
know what I'm saying and nobody helps
him to it ok like well that's God's well
nobody in the audience responds nobody
on stage response hyung is literally
playing the guitar he's pinned down
under a rock and nobody makes a move
never stop playing even in the audience
nobody reacts it's like too much Jesus
these guys are all I don't know I guess
it was meant to be right if the cross
falls on you then the rule is I think
it's in the Bible that you just let them
die God's like peace [ __ ] Bumi
really gets taken odds a heavy cross
bike so so late playing lady notices
it's like okay well do we just continue
I mean he's all God is obviously smite
me you know that commercial back in the
90s when for dare they're like this is
your brain on drugs and they crack an
egg mm-hmm she wouldn't have seen that
growing up really nobody remembers that
no I I remember of course I'm saying
helo wouldn't I've seen it I'm not
asking he'll oh yeah for sure
so this is your this is your brain on
Jesus this is your brain on Jesus all
these people are just too much Jesus we
got the picture of Zach I got no problem
with Jesus but too much Jesus oh we got
a shirtless pic um for younger that a
nice let's see what I have
yeah it's when I started my weight loss
turn that dude damn boy you didn't have
a chin but you look yeah I mean you look
you did thank you
I need the key to my ass I would have
never just imagine me man what I would
look like with the chanyeol oh I look
good huh
I'm weird or not with the chat Oh what
age were you here I mean how long ago I
was a junior in high school so when you
lost weight did you start getting like a
bunch of ass I mean what was that like
how do people react to it in high
schools it was definitely a shock I
definitely got a lot more attention if
you will that's amazing you might have
been like dude this is awesome you know
then I started to grow my hair out oh
[ __ ] we got the rock and roll here we
lost the compound's did your dick grow I
don't know what that means
you know it does but I've heard that
when you lose weight your dick gets
bigger because I guess you have more
blood to go circulate I swear to God
when you get fat your dick shrinks
really you're right I swear to God I
think it's a great reason you lose the
fat around the light I've never heard
that the Fupa area right it looks yeah I
was about to say I don't think it
actually gets bigger it's that
everything it's right in your portion to
everything else but I think your
erection quality improves is that right
Zach that's also your life quality in
general yeah I think yeah it does
you got a veneer he's good for you Zach
I'm proud of you
thank you and you've kept it off for a
long time yeah I've gone up and down I
mean my skinniest I was like 185 which
was just way too skinny for a 6-3 you
got a but I'm like at two-two time right
now I just maintain you know you
wouldn't want on the weekends and then
during the week it's uh you know back to
the routine what's the routine what is
it yeah we don't still a lot of protein
keto still no no bread just I try and
avoid bread so you eat you eat bread on
the weekend
yeah but you know you gotta limit
yourself no bread after breakfast no I
actually don't have bread with bread do
you eat a loaf of bread when you finish
breakfast cuz that's what I did this
before like a back ed early it was like
it was a little like yeah it was like
did you dip it in butter no I would have
if there was some around that's the best
char you kidding the bread dipped in
butter I died early for that [ __ ] it's
so explained to even he just Kido he
like you would have said that kudos
[ __ ] I think it doesn't sound very
healthy but I agreed that just try
cutting our bread yeah that alone will
do a lot are you allowed to eat
vegetables on keto yes you say just like
steak and Gino you can have you can have
vegetables but you just gotta like avoid
the sugar so like I don't need a lot of
fruits like apples or they have a bunch
of sugar in it hmm so look fruit TV
Eirene occasion I'll have like an orange
or I love watermelon
that's food you better watch out for the
watermelon yeah soupy it's got [ __ ] it's
got sugar in it damn yeah it's just like
you got to get yourself in a certain
mindset and you just gotta say [ __ ]
and do it okay I can go Kido Kido plus
feeding window equals bliss keto plus
feeding window would be like a huge
weight loss bro epic weight loss you can
do it you can do it you think I should
just do keto or just feeding window try
keto for two weeks see how you feel cuz
I guarantee you will see results didn't
I try or Acuto and I didn't lose weight
or it did something I don't think you're
really committed to it yeah you said you
were doing keto at one point but I don't
know I don't know well dude the proof is
in the pudding here with Zac I'm
motivated it sounds incredible yeah I'd
love to get my my erection quality up
it's not bad but it's like like when I
was a young man my erection was like
powerful it was like impressive you know
just look at your dick and you're like
good dude [ __ ] yeah bro no I don't do
that anymore I was like I was pushing to
like a 3x shirt I was like a
40-something waist like I just Lordy
yeah I mean I'm
far off those measurements my dude you
are you don't I mean Adam she used to be
38 infants and I don't really fit in
though yeah 38 to tight fit to be honest
not a super touch I'm mostly upset
because we used to measure clothing on
Ethan too and usually on Teddy fresh we
have like a fit model and we would make
the samples in a size large because
that's what he thin wears and we could
we couldn't like try it on Ethan and try
it on someone even a model like large is
kind of like a lot of people were large
but now you messed it all up so that's
why he was upset yeah well we gotta do
something about that yeah specifically
my erection quality though cuz I want to
go from like a sex like up to it I know
I'm like thirty I don't really know what
do you mean by quality like isn't it
either that or not no dude quality is my
quality it's like it's like come on dude
quality is like it's bigger it's
stronger it's harder its glorious it's
like it's like it's just incredible it's
this beautiful thing
I don't know quality of an erection okay
it's gone from like a 75% to 100% the
difference between limestone and like
diamond Wow
you understand and see that all the guys
on this stands for sure I mean my dick
works let's get that straight
you could it that's why I'm asking what
do you mean because it it works better
it's like it works better it's harder
it's a little bigger so what are you
waiting for
I'm not waiting fraid they don't want a
feeding window I'm gonna feeding window
post Kido it's impossible okay just try
it for two weeks
I'm telling you will see results okay
two weeks here we go we're in but so do
I am I out of the feeding window yeah
none of Saudi thank you do you do you
what kind of like snacks can you eat
when you're on Keita
or do you just forego I I tend to have
like these protein bars that are like
super low in carbs protein bars yeah
those sound good yeah I can give you a
name but they're a lot of sugar and
those I buy like the low sugar like less
than one gram two grams like this some
of that and you just hit those hard
during the day no you got I mean like
anything in life you're gonna limit
yourself but I mean like that is your
problem
there's no easy way doing it we're in a
way that you have to limit yourself its
Kido no carbs lose 70 pounds
all right I'm gonna do I'm gonna do the
and I can't eat fruit that's crazy I
like fruit you can but not to want
moderation not too much fruit I mean
what do you snack on now Oh meals off no
what do i snack that I snack on they
don't do much snacking I just eat
big-ass meals like last night you was
good well if there's cookies in the
house or any kind of pastries or stuff
like that you don't eat at all yeah
either goes let's get a tally for you
okay
look at the menu uh chicken with a
shitload of cheese on top and marinara
sauce on the side some vegetables a
potato a salad and i'm tara misu granted
but you ate most of it yeah that's a
shitload of bread
so you eat everything but the bread and
don't touch the throw myself
don't touch the bread don't touch the
tiramisu you can have with was the
chicken breaded or was it just no not
breaded so you can have the chicken the
cheese the marinara sauce with the
veggies no what about potato you know
paid up no potato no potato no potato
potato kind of sucks anyway what you
don't mean that
well when it comes as a side like with
chicken kind of salt good it was like
baked and it was like soaked in the
Marinero it was like insane I don't care
you all right let's go Quito two weeks
ACK and I better look like I better
loose how many pounds am I supposed to
look like five pounds I mean again it's
been you were losing like ten a month I
was losing yeah I was and I don't think
it was that healthy to drop that quickly
but yeah that's pretty drastic yeah I
just I was tired of like feeling
sluggish all the time you were like 16
years old - right 17 17 yeah it's
different at that age you know it's a
lot easier agreed well it's time to take
a break we didn't really talk about
anything about me being fat so hopefully
that was entertaining let's take a break
when we come back we're gonna watch the
new Star Wars trailer and lots of other
stuff we're going to talk about
pewdiepie ban Joker movie review in
there is a drama here brewing in the
podcast studio with Ian destroying the
bachelor segment we're gonna conclude
that and influencers giving out their
phone numbers that's actually just some
kind of scam and probably more about
feeding windows so stay tuned guys will
be R back
I was shocked when I heard this did you
know that 66% of men start to lose their
hair by age 35 so the minute you see
your hair start to thin or the Balts
parts bald spots start the form you
don't wait you never want to hear it's
too late it's 2019 hems can't connect
you to the medicine of science to help
you do something about keeping that
beautiful luscious hair in your head
where it belongs hems is helping guys be
the best versions of themselves with
fda-approved products and the best part
is you don't have to make that awkward
in-person doctor's visit or wait in the
pharmacy line just answer a few quick
questions online and a licensed
physician will review and determine if a
prescription is right for you I
recommend checking them out before it's
too late
and you have officially gone bald and
you're just a bald dude there's two
people in this world bald dudes and
dudes with their which one do you want
to be right ela no no maybe it's too
harsh but I think balding looks
distinguished but obviously some people
prefer to keep their hair Wow he was
saying this is off the rails let's go
back to the strip right now my listeners
can get started with the hems complete
hair kit for just 5 dollars while
supplies last
go to 4 hems calm /h 3 that's 4 hams
calm /h 3 now here's the disclaimer that
I have to read I'm gonna read it really
fast like a radio guy prescriptive
subject to doctors approval and required
online so call today with the physician
will be determined for the prescription
is appropriate see what was I for all
these as a safety information was that
do you think that passes prescriptions
are subject to doctor approval and
requires an online consultation with a
physician who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate C website
for full details and safety information
better ok thank you
do you want to know what makes the
ultimate toothbrush
yep is it Brussels that horn your gums
no is it Brussels that are soft and give
love to your gums yep is it a toothbrush
pulsates which dentists recommend yeah
is it a non pulsating toothbrush nope
exactly you know thank you
he'll we're talking about quick yolks
man to protect the olgerd back to do a
little to cleaned your mouth to an
extraordinary degree Oh for the little
starting price of $25 yup you know quick
sensitive vibrations with a built-in
timer gentle guide brush retentive
deliver stroke for dentists recommended
two minutes with 30 second pulses
ensuring and even cleaned quit
automatically delivers brush heads to
you every three months for clean new
bristles right on schedule
the sleek intuitive design is simple to
use and comes with a treble cat that
doubles as a mirror mount these
thoughtful features make brushing
something you actually want to do twice
everyday good habits matter to live a
healthier life helped formed fresh oral
habits with quick quick starts at just
$25 and you'll get your first refill at
get quipped calm slash h3 one more time
baby it's a simple way to support our
show is start brushing better but you
have to go to a get qu IP comm / h3 and
you get your first reap help do you feel
back for free yes that's right so go
right now to GE t qu IP comm /h 3 to get
the equip dream you're gonna put a dream
tube in your mouth is gonna vibrate and
pulse it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome dude
welcome back to the greatest show that's
ever existed out of breath just ran back
from the bathroom what do you know I
thought we had more time than Dan sticks
his head out the door he's like I'm all
the way down the hall at the bath
he goes 30 seconds so I go an all-out
sprint ends with me it's like storming
the beaches of Normandy up there no I'm
winded salt be riding the meathook
this guy's salt Bay man I just I don't
know why he gets all the love in our
favorite Turkish chef gets gets no
respect I mean this is the kind of
content you can expect from salt Bay and
go ahead and explain this to me if you
can dude is just on a meat hook and with
a knife a finger or a knife there's to
be a knife nothing happened hey we're
back did what lie break I was like four
minutes but weird by quick
hila describe to me what salt bay is
doing here first of all that meat hits
that corner real hard this Jackie Chan
but he just stabs it and jumps off the
hook like bro that this you know I
stabbed the meat it's all freaking it's
in a refrigerating room why are you just
stabbing a carcass bro it's not cooking
so epic he doesn't even take the hard
turn he's a [ __ ] you see how hard that
meat turned and he bailed before the
hard turn which is what I wanted to see
salt Bay get go for the ride of his life
mm-hmm so that's the kind of
high-quality content you can expect from
salt Bay what is he doing instead it was
off the hook
off the hook thank you him yeah why
didn't you say that on the mic he just
muttered the owners breath I got like
he's so pasty and why you got to
contribute to the show if you got gaps
if you got laughs if you got one-liners
please you know open your mic is hit
that's true kim jeong-hoon on a white
horse this was pretty epic the glorious
leader of North Korea the last horse
left in North Korea that hasn't been
named yet him John
negative space on the first picture this
guy is such a ding-dong bro how is this
guy the glorious leader there's
literally nothing glories first of all
what's with the supercut nothing a $10
haircut it's like a box and then he's
got two little hooks on the side yeah
what is that
he got so fat bro when he became the
glorious leader have you seen him young
no he was he he was like pretty fit kim
jeong-hoon
young he was like a pretty fit little
spicy little twink oh no he was always
chubby I'm wrong yeah I was thinking him
his brother yeah he's a chubby little
[ __ ] and he liked him that's him
with his glorious leader dad and Mickey
Mouse that's a regular dude they just
wants to chill at the Disneyland you
know what I'm saying this a healthy
looking kid yeah you looked like a
healthy guy who eats kids guy he's a
fact he's just like he looks like
Cartman in real life like Asian Cartman
you know what I mean it doesn't make
sense I thought he was all fit what the
hell did I see maybe it was his brother
yeah must have been his brother cuz it
looks like he's always been a chubby
little sucker maybe it was this I don't
know
regardless he's on a horse and he looks
like he's LARPing or something real-life
role-playing he looks like he's LARPing
Skyrim he's on a mission on the next a
little bunny My Little Pony role-playing
girl from my strange addiction oh you
think he's Pony fetish it looks like
that and just reminds me also as horses
like all like our fantasies fantasy
she'd out till like he looks like he's
on his way to slay some ogres Shadowfax
but he is the ogre Shadowfax thank you
Dan that's the Lord of the Rings
reference for all you nerds out there
[Music]
this is like a legit photo shoot - I
wonder this is just PR like glorious
leader taking a ride - yeah they do this
every so often this is like a sacred
mountain in Korea that he's riding atop
so it's like a Christmas card for all of
Korea I don't think they have Christmas
in North Korea but it could be wrong
yeah that country's so [ __ ] up well
there you have it glorious leader in a
Scotty's a Skyrim our NPC what else we
got we got a new scooter video granddad
takes his daughter for the ride of her
life until the friggin River do this is
awesome it's full sweetness they calling
her Nana - hello
Nana's like please dude your life is
over I was kind of hoping they would you
know really take a dip in today there's
a real fear in their eyes you know so
what happened here exactly did she hit
the handle tickets - yeah and Nana tried
to correct course but it was all too
late yeah bad idea what if that scooter
is out for the count that looks like
grandpa is that Nana mister that's just
like grandpa but somebody said yeah yes
I understand I thought I said someone
say man yeah yeah look she's driving a
Nana well maybe now's why Anna's
reporting all watching fantastic telling
you guys scooters were dangerous you saw
what happened to Bobby Lee
scooter in the wrong hands is uh can be
a true danger oh this one you guys will
enjoy scumbag of the decade award this
is a coveted new category here on the
HTTP podcast I saw this today scumbag of
the decade now this is a famous
Brazilian singer who came to Los Angeles
for a gig went to Disneyland and the
first thing he does it is and I'm gonna
show you the video he posted to
Instagram he goes this is what he says
in Portuguese so you understand what
he's saying
he says just arrived at Disney bro check
this out and then he points the camera
at a girl you'll see and he says dear
God okay so here's the video scumbag of
the decade award goes to this dude here
you are really not gonna like this I was
floored by this this guy's like a
grown-ass man and a public figure no
less it's a girl with cancer we'll take
care
I didn't land my dudes what is wrong
with you bro that's so crazy so she's
looking at you to make you at least like
bro like you are electric soulless he
says dear God maybe I'm just trying to
think like walk what could he think
could that well I read I read a follow
up you're wondering there's no way that
this guy yeah is this heartless and
trashy well he lost a lot of uh he's
starting to lose shows because of this
he's losing deals yeah
as he should I mean come on you're a
public figure but I'll have some class
he he said in his defense I just thought
the outfit was funny I wasn't trying to
make fun of a girl with cancer but again
if we look at it through that lens I'm
still really not giving it a little girl
she's a little girl with and she looks
completely normal for a luau exactly elf
it's fine the outfit is totally fine
dude imagine being that guy he scored
lucky he's a pop star in Brazil he's
that Disneyland what does he do targets
a poor young girl and makes fun of her
while she's looking at mr. part of the
yeah can you at least not like do it in
her face so this guy is losing all of
his deals and may his career may be over
from this single Instagram video so um
scumbag of the decade award goes to this
Brazilian singer and I hope that this
that this little girl Disney reaches out
to and gives a lifetime pass to Disney
mm-hmm that would be a magical thing
when they're not unbelievable
thoughts anyone have thoughts on that
scumbag a decade I mean what is that if
I can say yeah I'm trying to look this
up to find out what his name I didn't
see his name maybe you can find yeah and
it lets shame him Thank You Zakir and
would you like to shame today yes he
deserves his word he deserves me more
thank you
well there you have it now guys it's
time to squash the beef and this beef is
on a manny sandwich he and the intern as
you may all know recently was the center
of a drama here on the HD podcast the
greatest show ever made because we had
put together an entire segment to find
in true love
it was the bachelor with an h3 it was
inspired by our favorite show The
Bachelor which actually is going to be
returning next month this isn't a
sponsor I'm just you know speaking my
mind I do like that show and I'm looking
forward to the return though I'm not a
fan of Peter who they chose but that's
beside the point
yeah Ian we set him up we had two
finalists and a third wild card
I found out had approached him in the
DMS he had been having a serious
conversation with had been making a real
connection with her and he never told us
about it when I found out I said Ian you
need to bring her in as a wild card to
protect the sanctity of the show and he
says no he refused to include her as a
contestant so I said okay Ian then the
show is over the integrity of the show
is over you're already interested in
another girl she came at you through a
private eye through a DDM do you aren't
she circumvented the proper channels of
approaching him it's the chain of
command you know you don't circumvent
the chain of command that's 101 do you
know that Ian you do not circumvent the
chain of command
don't answer that wait you'll have your
turn and so we had a we had a
falling-out there was huge drama and we
had a falling-out I'm gonna be
there was lots of memes even on the
podcast which I enjoyed seeing I was
happy to see that also I do want to have
a HTTP podcasting meme corner so if you
guys enjoy these memes keep submitting
them to the HDH reproduction subreddit
cuz these are fantastic oh wait this
came too early
did you see that you know he's standing
up right now actually getting ready to
go in so here's some use today's podcast
when they started talking about the
bachelor Ethan in ela dreaming Zack
screaming and crying and Dan what does
that convey damn the cat it was just
hitting the chips yeah yeah thousand
points I love to see you all engaged
with the podcast this is always great
yeah I love that too
let me get this scumbag off the TV we've
got another one here there was actually
a lot of powerful names here here we go
the family meeting Dan momma poppa
salaried employee and Ian sacred 8
Bachelor rules that's right that's right
and then got there sue so vinegar oh
yeah they how could I forget a Photoshop
the chips in for dead man that's great
and then finally we have another one
here we go
DM girl in h3 dating show contestant
spot-on
respond to this well you're gonna have
to call him in yeah okay why don't you
come in already in while I'm looking at
these memes and here comes in the
salaried employee so there's that he's
made one dollar from the show and then
we had our honorable mention unrelated
to the drama
another meme I wanted to give love to
this is a meme that reference how I say
nobody's listening it says nobody's
listening that but what past 45 minutes
Ethan impossible
well that's true we're about that moment
now so thank you to everyone who stuck
around it
there's probably nobody listening anyway
about [ __ ] push on so Ian says comes
to me now we found a way to squash the
beef now Ian how are you feeling after
our last episode level with me I'm ready
for this all to be over like really bad
so I've drafted up a contract that
essentially requires this to be fully
done and never mentioned again okay so
if you want to just take a look at that
I will I haven't seen this before okay
but what Ian approached me with and I
just want to stress that this isn't my
idea and I would never propose this
support young in you are so excited you
jumble in it it's I mean you brought I
don't I wouldn't ever put you up - I was
backed into a corner a little bit I
think I will not really I mean not you
you did you not proposed this to me
because there no I figured yes or no I
had to come with something okay that you
guys would accept and this seemed and we
did and you did I had to it was a
proposed yes you know okay you have to
come up with an offer we couldn't really
it had to be 10 said to me he said if
you promise not to ever if you promise
to drop that bachelor C season of Ian's
and oh I haven't seen it yet I have a
feeling I'll be making some amendments
to this no we'll see you know it's yeah
I don't my lawyer here I might have to
afford this I think just don't even read
it I think you should just start no come
on
anyway he says me if I eat a jar of
mayonnaise
will you leave this alone I said Ian and
never talk about it again I said in I
love you and I accept your terms
already we have well we're all dying to
rid this is all outlined in the contract
okay and again with this tiny jar he
went now Z by the way
it's already set the precedent for what
eating a jar of mayonnaise is on this
show we have precedential we have a
precedent for what a jar of mayonnaise
me that's a full-sized jar so you come
in with this little [ __ ]
by the way best foods this is the real
deal this is good man he doesn't even
like off-brand okay uh-huh I'm gonna
accept it because I'm gonna accept on a
technicality well it is a jar it's a jar
at last it's a jar but what I'm gonna
tell you right now in is that if you
don't finish this jar then the terms are
not accepted because I'm giving you this
tiny jar and you're already kind of
grounds for dropping this deal already
with this I think that we need to work
this out through the contract yep so let
me pass this to you let me okay
this was your idea I just do want to
stress that wow that's a lot of well
it's a lot of tax no the signee of this
document hereby agrees to immediately
cease all discussion regarding the pilot
season segment of The Bachelor and
various topics related said subject
matter these topics may include such
designations as Australian girl Idaho
girl wild card and other affiliation so
can I not reference it it it I'd prefer
you not to that language was pretty
clear it's pretty and I will I will
bring that up if I feel like do you have
a remedy if I do bring it up
oh I pulled the plug you just send that
the show is over I have that power in
the back in exchange the party I'm home
been eating chips right now just curious
I wish that can you grab me some set up
shots where Dan's eating it than that
let's watch the damn this car an
exchange party in question now known as
Ian the salaried employee will attempt
to consume a jar of mayonnaise purchase
at his own discretion
this contract does not stipulate a full
consumption of the jar and the contract
is
not invalidate it if the chart is not
fully consumed but rather must be
honored upon reasonable endeavor of full
jar depletion now is that at my
discretion the full jar for the attempt
you like it so good job yes then I at my
discretion I can say that the agreement
has been fulfilled I think it I don't I
don't trust you I think a ILA's
discretion I think is you won't take
four bytes you're gonna you're gonna
quit after four bytes Zack Zack thinks
he's Mayo hotshot now nothing on me yes
I agree if I power in you you look can I
trust you yeah you'll fulfill a good
faith effort yes okay and we both agree
that he will be the arbiter of this
agreement okay deal
all right so okay but rather must be
hard upon okay yeah yeah yeah this
contract is not dependent on stabilized
devouring stabilized devouring of said
mayonnaise and in the circumstance of
involuntary bodily injection of
substance consumed the contract is still
vowed on all points must remain and here
to it that's fine yes I do vomit yeah
the contract stands I am fine with that
okay this agreement does not require
minimal ounce requirements and the size
of the jar is not relevant to the
request of the line you mean yes this
jar is accepted do you agree to those
terms yeah I'm fine with these all right
well here here's a but well want one
point we do need to I think go ahead in
Josiah they are Dion I think like if we
can reference this whole thing in
retrospect not continuing the drama or
inquiring further but like referring to
it as something that has happened as a
historical moment on the show you can
say that it exists we can reference it
as a historical moment on the pilot you
can say there was a pilot season the
pilot scene did fail here's where here's
what all we cannot couldn't tell me to
further elaborate any will agree to this
I will not inquire about any of your
relationships with Australian girl Idaho
girl or
card on the show or anybody no
relationship yeah no I could talk about
it but I won't compel you to further
talk about you can't slander me on it
anymore slander you what's that I mean
that's I disagree with some of the you
know paintings that were made of my
character but like what we're not gonna
this is we're done no I want to know
we're I got peace I am not engaging on
I'm about to eat mayonnaise okay but I
avoid these I can talk about it but I
can't compel you to spit I will not
compel you to to speak further you can
say to the extent that the segment may
have failed in certain ways that you
believe mm-hmm but that's it no more
endure how you gonna prove slander I
have to consult my lawyer these are hard
to prove yes I am altering the contract
in let's remember who's I mean let's
remember what's what this is your idea
this is our segment that you ruined
that's not true but I don't even want to
engage in that conversation anymore I'm
out okay okay so I will not you both to
sign this but hold on I need our eating
I need to make a minute I don't think
you well here we don't need two men we
have a verbal agreement we can reference
this I will not could tell you to speak
about this experience or any of the
girls mmm I do not agree the Nazis I
know continued I will slander you know
no continued drama creating its what hey
we'll let it be well let yes we'll talk
about it as a historical moment but I
will let it be I will let it be so sorry
Ethan that's my signature okay a 1022
and I'm gonna need a letter sign on the
second line if you could oh thank you is
this calling sense get the best part
hands down I think that's that's how you
know I'm serious
that is my signature yes did you date no
not yet
it does say effective as of today do we
need a do we need Oh degree yeah yeah
we can get that afterwards we can have
so we cannot say Australia girl Idaho no
man talk about all these things but we
cannot compel it further we will talk
about these peoples here they're gone
right yeah no no you have to make a
good-faith effort
can we pipe in some music or something
here for the big moment this is gonna be
so good
that's a tiny jar bro you really fist up
that useful
you should really finish that entire jar
like you can't take that Klaus as a
[ __ ] out to not eating that whole thing
I'm going to do a good faith attempt but
that no I see I don't like that [ __ ]
sign disagree okay just eat it you look
you're the judge eat the damn man you
know a greater here okay take that
person that's all you in just get just
jump in on cold water oh my god like a
band-aid you got this hold on good he
got that down that was good I love that
eating mayonnaise is the benchmark of
punishment on this show somehow talk to
me that's [ __ ] disgusting
that's awful you seem like a pretty good
shape though high five oh god I can't be
in here
that's alright we got not for bye put
the trash can over by your chair oh you
did are you dance Dan you really do
think for everything you're great
producer thank you you're in good shape
so don't even that was a big bite yeah
Ethan I'm just saying he's in good shape
not doing good
come on okay Gil exact look yeah yeah
you don't encourage him here yeah you're
doing great you're right I should
encourage you you're doing it [ __ ]
awesome you're knocking those down
you're may go no you're putting Zach to
shame bro oh come on
did Zach drink water we have liquid he
can have water I think I need some water
bring in some water stats Ya Ya Ya let's
Lacroix your favorite no no
my stomach is you're probably getting
pretty low there but Zack you're having
some real competition Zack what are you
he's grabbing the water so eggy and
nasty oh you're doing great man keep it
up this is truly awful to watch
Zack go good get back in the mic I want
to hear from you we got I need Zacks
opinion on my technique here does the
nose pinching help I don't think so yeah
okay what do you need well what do you
think about this cuz he's actually
making a really good I think he's got a
shot of finishing the jar I'm very proud
of him I feel how still queasy really
after you look strong though he can't
quit so hard not to puke
you can't allow them to quit right how
many bites are you in I think three
things like three five I think you're
almost done you there's like two more if
you got if you scrape the sides and get
just like let's get more big bites and
you can just consider it you can you can
move on with the wild card girl in and
you can just live happily in your
private life is it hit me in the bottom
of the stomach I'm feeling it that's a
that's a good it might throw Limon down
this room out behind that [ __ ] help
you're doing great this is so gross
super impressed bro bite number four is
Dan gonna do this to it I was just
thinking I'm gonna have to do this
eventually when I spoke up oh yeah this
is the way to solve everything that is
laughing Dan you're not eating chef Ian
you're doing bite number four ian is
he's getting in there by number four
that was a big scoop Phil let me see
what you got left it is so disgusting it
hit you in the Taunton here but I mean
there's definitely like three I would
say 3/4 gone yeah definitely oh that
smells strong
what's the babies are though please make
me stop well also Zack if I recall had
like a big ass serving spoon which I
have I ate half of the bigger one yes
this is still a good this is a few
sandwiches worth here yeah that's easy
one more bite and can I be done no more
tomorrow it's two more bites
come on because if you took you said a
ferret time let me just say you know can
do one more bite than he can do to let's
just keep going
oh I'm saying if he says he's got one
more bite then he's got to I'm not gonna
lie to you Ian you're gonna you're gonna
puke later I'm not encourage him there
are like wine is the majority and then
there's like another little but ELA he
can do it and you can do it she seems to
be accepting one body he didn't give a
verdict I'm accepting one but Ron make
sure it's big let's see the size it's
pretty much gone okay that's which is
it's a much empty well not honestly I
think you ate more than is active hold
on you wait this I'm I think I'm getting
a okay oh yeah yeah yeah yeah get that
in there got in there score Falls
alright don't plug your nose more than
Zak I do well I gotta plug my nose I got
it nope do a plug is no suck
good job Ian I'm proud of you man you
earned this
you earned it yeah probably you earned
this you earned this unbelievable the
culmination of the bachelor season one
pilot comes to an end with Ian eating a
small jar man it who could have seen
this coming folks what a nobody
you never know what's gonna happen in
The Bachelor you might find true love
and you might find the inside of a best
foods mayonnaise jar so congratulations
to you
we're very proud all right
I can't believe I'm taking this copy how
are you feeling like that's about yet so
I feel really gross I feel like I feel
like if you know did you have trouble
with that last night that one was
hitting me
hit go down you're like does it stick
getting like little you're gonna puke
I'm tasting it so strong really
yeah puke and that do you like I feel
like a sandwich right now it's just
slathered up on my bread and meat to me
to balance your so it's really close
[Music]
okay I gotta go right thank you well
that was amazing and thank you I
appreciate this you're lucky yellow is
the judge but I mean you you definitely
made a good-faith effort you didn't
[ __ ] up
I'll give you that credit so so there
you go mum's the word on The Bachelor
and I want to stress to everyone who
thinks I'm being cruel or let's say oh
oh you're bought you're not allowed to
make your employees eat mayonnaise as a
punishment mm-hmm well it was his idea
okay yeah I hear him coughing backstage
Khamis get any updates how's he's fine
it's fine yeah he's fine cool that was
exciting is this the best show on earth
or what do we do we always have
something going on here in the issue
podcast studio this is the greatest show
ever made outer I'll say that every time
you don't need a sound bite me Wow so
you think yeah I don't think so I think
that's impossible that he ate more than
Zach I mean it was impressive and I give
him all the credit in the world but I'm
gonna have to watch Zach hit a full jar
of mayonnaise with a servings but he
didn't finish it no but that thing was
like a quarter of the size Zach was
going way more aggressive in flute to he
hit like ciri was serving SIA okay Zach
was shoveling this I give you in a lot
of credit though yeah I'm very proud of
him I guess that is still the mayonnaise
champ but use the mayonnaise print what
am I gonna do that I'm gonna have to eat
a jar managed to make up for either u2
and Dan then man is definitely enough
the manager for
before the end of the year that's
honestly that's gonna be exciting what's
with you why are you all why why are you
have your areas been so dan why are you
why are you drunk good my called in here
you always crank they see honestly
easing in here honestly honestly that's
why I'm getting on keto won't be hot all
the time yeah he's running a real hot
yeah I got a sweater and a beanie too
yes well I like the way it looks okay
did we didn't watch the new Star Wars
trailer let's watch this everyone's
hyped about the new Star Wars wait you
gonna put it on yeah it's gonna get us
dang you can't claim me for showing the
[ __ ] trailer that you want everyone
to watch you agree doesn't make any
sense
they're totally gonna dingus we'll all
dispute that [ __ ] all the way to [ __ ]
bail out I mean maybe I shouldn't show
we can also skip it it's always
something somebody's gonna claim this
episode every someone always claims the
episode absolutely P till I get to the
main stories you want to just cut to the
chase but people want to know what we
think about the Star Wars trailer they
do a Star Wars
I'll tell you I don't care why people
care about trailers so much that's what
I don't get the trailer hype well in
general if you there's a movie or super
excited about you get a little tease
there about what what it's about
so it's exciting ela I like trailers
let's watch
so just update the last one Luke
Skywalker drink some tit purple tip milk
and Princess Leia went for a spacewalk
it was I think it was widely held to be
bad the last one can we all agree on
that I mean I thought it was terrible
but I think it was pretty eyes widened I
don't think virtual I think like 5050 a
lot of people liked it a lot let's say
mixed but the third one is usually the
good one it is like are we not in
December I have to yes I have to say I'm
gonna stop pausing a sec the Star Wars
the third one is always the best one
it's a weird card disagree what
harshness agree I agree the third one is
always the best one a star wire is the
best of your eternity without a doubt
Return of the Jedi no what about the
charger being swung there was also one
was about more than that
the third one was like DISA it was good
I most people do hold the third one of
the prequels to be the first two were
like total ass but then so I'm just
saying that this one from the original
three you're saying the third one
everybody loves the third one Return of
the Jedi that's not people's favorites
of the originals no no Empire is widely
considered to be the best second one
yeah that's the second one that
disagrees and I disagree you're
overruled what does the end think he
agrees with me I'm with Dan on this one
Oh anyway listen to say okay whatever
forget everything I said
it's an instinct
[Music]
feeling
the force brought together
[Music]
we're not home
good people will fight if we leave them
[Music]
people keep telling me they know me
[Music]
and I wonders
[Music]
you know and stuff can fill up the
insult
now people I know
you're coming together
[Music]
I'm doing
and don't like trailers or typical
hating you taking one last look sir my
friends okay that seam is [ __ ] stupid
yes II think Pele doesn't even know them
his friends are Luke Skywalker and
Princess Leia you know and I'm not
having an emotional reaction to c-3po go
and kamikaze just like bro
hello you don't know these [ __ ] I
hate that they're doing some emotional
play on that line that you pointed out
of no one no one knows me it was already
so bad that was very in selling more
than any insel moment in the Joker I
this trailer is awful I hate it because
they just show you so much and it just
tells me always that the movies bad mmm
I like trailers that are like cryptic
like this is cryptic I don't know this
is already too long in my opinion I
don't think this is not I mean there's
there's where they show you the entire
plot of the movie yeah those are like
the extreme awful ones there I think
they're too don't necessarily know
what's happening in this just from this
trailer but that longing was just stupid
it's Star Wars no like I feel like it
gets a pass I don't know what just it's
just Star Wars like everyone's gonna see
it in love it I passed on c-3po guv
Kamikaze
we haven't seen the movie yet we don't
know why do you keep saying he's
Kamikaze him well duh that's like
foreshadowing that he's dying I guess
he's going to sacrifice his life to save
the [ __ ] rewatching I mean obviously
he's gonna die it's so other people
taking one last look sir
my friends obviously he's gonna die
hello those aren't his friends [ __ ] are
they to him well maybe that's right
maybe they go through a lot during the
movie I guess without it though
[Music]
to fear
gets easy lay understand we didn't get
an after day money itself in reality the
or death City
the saga will answer the cook method
[Music]
they team up like they kind of spoil
that right like look they team up they
team up their Palpatine goes your
undoing was you coming together so they
team up against Palpatine they just
struck that together obvious what did I
say that's what I mean this is the kind
of trailer that just goes on forever
with you awful oh by the way that's
sound byte there's a little mangoes it's
like twist
cuz there they do a little uh Luke
Skywalker and then they bring in Leia
I think that's Leia and it's like yeah
it's just a little mangled I said that
sound three ways will be with you Oh
sounds like a totally different
situation
am I wrong
hard to see until we see it I guess so
boy I think I mean look I think it's got
a good chance of being good I think that
the last one was truly and honestly and
horrifically just awful the whole
subplot with the band space bandit and
freeing the [ __ ] space horses was
truly one of the worst moments in
cinematic history and I mean that and I
was I was thoughtless I hated every
minute of that but if we are talking
about trailers and just write it as a
trailer this is a very awful trailer I
disagree I think it's fine
says it it's not a Star Wars trailer
like a typical [ __ ] I will tell you
this you know the writer and director
changed on this film actually it's the
one who did the first one right there
yeah yeah yeah so the first one I loved
the second one I hated and the third one
is the guy who made the first one
correct so a room so yeah so that that's
promising but you come I'm not talking
about the movie I'm talking about the
trailer I mean I'm gonna walk I'm in the
middle is a basic trailer yeah it's a
it's definitely not as hype as I mean I
actually think the trailer I hated the
last movie but I thought the trailer for
the last movie was pretty good like it
had me excited for it and this one I
definitely feel yeah I don't know I'm
seeing it we're all watching that I'm
going at midnight I mean yeah come on I
already have my second no I'm gonna
watch it that's that's how I think this
is sparking a conversation that I am
personally passionate about trailers
yeah I feel you on that most trailers do
suck most of them suck and this is so
basic for Star Wars well we saw I should
have a better trailer we saw Joker what
was that movie where they gave away the
entire year plus it's yeah raising it's
like it's like Vin Diesel was a
detective who lost his whole family and
then went on revenge but then found a
friend had changed his life and fell in
love and he got his revenge and like Oh
who'sa blood blood shot looks cool
actually it says it's a trailer that
goes on right well but but it was just
going on forever and you could tell the
whole story
but blood shot did give away a lot now
that I think about it is that the
trailer that you're talking about no
it's not it was something on him he's
got another one coming it gave away it
wasn't necessarily Vin Diesel I was just
okay but then Vin Diesel gets
double-crossed by his best friend that
you thought was his friend the whole
time but he can't trust anybody by the
last act to the film yeah that shit's
crazy bro but on the topic of film we
did see Joker and I would like to talk
about yeah Joker hysteria um I
personally first of all really liked
this film I mean - I'm a fan of the
Batman universe Batman is my favorite
superhero and let me tell you why he's
just a human being he doesn't have super
powers he's just a genius and he's rich
and he's got good principles and morals
and he fights for justice but he's also
a little twisted because he witnessed
his barons being murdered
Batman is real he's epic and I love
Gotham and I love the whole Batman
universe okay now Joker I thought I've
always loved Joker - on this con its own
I mean it's a great character
Joker probably is one of the if not
greatest comic book villains I mean most
iconic even in just popular culture
right Joker's is awesome and you
nobody's ever really tackled a Joker
origin story it's always remained a
total mystery and what this movie
attempts to do is tell an origin story
about Joker we have to remember that
this movie because it tries to take a
realistic look into the life of of this
man who becomes Joker it's in Gotham
City we are in a comic book
setting if Gotham is this just the city
is in ruin it's just it's like over the
top just oppressive it's just all it's
like everything bad about metropolis in
New York because it's really sad New
York Times you know
50 it's a great depression level of
poverty and I loved also had they made
the city look and just it was obviously
New York but you felt like you were in
Gotham City which is awesome and then
what was really I'm trying not to give
away major spoilers so if you haven't
seen the movie I think I'll try my best
not to give away major spoilers but what
I love the most about this film is that
so it's a lot about Bruce Wayne's father
Thomas Wayne and in the Batman stories
we always hear about Batman's father as
this great philanthropist he was trying
to save the city he was like this great
infallible incredible man that was
murdered at the hands of a petty
criminal who the very person who was
trying to save and Gotham right but what
we see is actually the the other side of
the coin what we see is is like I'm more
realistic right he's a he's a greedy
arrogant businessman who looks down on
the poor and the criminals in the
destitute he is an upperclassman he's a
snob
he's power-hungry and we even get to see
what's the butler's name when uh Alfred
we even get to see Alfred who idolizes
and protects Bruce and raises Bruce in
the stead of his father who's also kind
of a kind of a douche to kind of a snob
they're elitist they look down on the
lower classmen and Thomas Wayne is
running for mayor and you see at least
from the perspective of someone who's on
the bottom rungs of society that this
guy really really is not is really not
looking out for them at least from their
perspective and to me when you look at
the Joker mythology and Batman he's
basically a cult leader he has all these
worshipers who dress up like clowns and
do his bidding and get him resources and
and you know
they basically do his master plans and
what you see is kind of an explanation
for how the Joker becomes a cult-like
figure with followers and worshipers who
are willing to join his movement it's
not even really a movement he's really a
an anarchist in the film he's not
political in any way he's just an
anarchist who's kind of just broke
he's just broke by his his upbringing by
society and I thought first of all I
really liked seeing all these classic
tropes from a different perspective from
the Batman universe and what what struck
me the most is there I just kept hearing
about how he's like in cell and
promoting violence and I just what
struck me is just how I didn't see that
at all watching the film he to me
strikes me as a typical antihero I mean
he's just an antihero he's a violent
criminal he's a murderer he's just a
total lunatic um by hero or villain he's
not a villain in this story he's an
antihero I wouldn't consider him a
villain but but mm but you can see how
he became he is a slippery slope they
show him kind of getting lost in the
sauce as they say but but but it's not
there's a relatable descent into madness
which I like you want you you see how it
happens and I didn't really see the film
condoning his behavior I didn't see them
making any political statements I
certainly didn't see the insulting
because there was a moment where he was
involved with a woman I liked that
dynamic they didn't force it they just
did it enough they didn't play it up to
a point where was obnoxious and then
when when something happened they moved
right along never was you violent
towards a woman or in Sully or even
mention sex or even having negative
opinions about women at all I didn't get
the in so vile
em at all people say it's overly violent
not really I mean that part I don't get
it wasn't really overly violent if I'm
being honest the violence was very
tasteful in a very tasteful I mean I
thought it was like dark and bald I
guess to make a video about him but
that's what I like about it I thought
that was awesome but people love all the
Marvel movies and there's violence and
those I don't get what's the difference
indiscriminate violence it was it was a
part of the plot you know what I mean it
wasn't just he was just indiscriminately
bloody and murderous I thought it was
fantastic I really enjoyed the film and
something I noticed about it too is that
if you go to like Metacritic or around
tomato it has a very low score like 50
60 % but if you go to IMDB it's like
number 15 of all time so the users the
audience loves it the critics hate it
which is something I noticed happening a
lot more I wanted to read some of the
comments from the critics because this
is what I went in with the expectation
of of seeing stuff like let's see New
York Times we are now at the phase of
the argument cycle what actual ticket
buyers have a chance to see what all the
fuss is about
which means that it's also time for me
to say my idea he says are you kidding
me to be worth art this is too much it's
too much The New Yorker the result is a
movie of cynicism so vast and pervasive
as to render the viewing experience even
emptier then it's slapdash aesthetic
does Joker tries to question the expert
exploration of mental illness for
entertainment and the consequence of
society of banding its weakest members
but the film is in turn exploiting
mental illness and using it as an excuse
for Arthur's nefarious actions this
feels tone-deaf in a way where mental
illness is being wrongfully linked to
mass violence in the u.s. the film is
aware enough to draw from great film
about toxic masculinity and loneliness
but not enough to critique Arthur's
behavior instead of painting them as
helpless alone or driven to violence by
forces out of his control dude I don't
see any political statement in this film
at all like I think these critics are
reading too deep into that's what I
think too like it's just also why let's
don't tell me what you think about
politically tell me did you enjoy the
film yeah that's what I was wrote what
are you talking about it's an artistic
form of art and the actor did so good I
just enjoyed it I was it was an amazing
performance by him I I thought that
aesthetic was great I don't know what
there's nothing about I enjoyed
everything I don't know what Time
magazine says Joker wants to be a movie
about emptiness of our culture instead
it's a prime example of it again I
disagree we're talking about Gotham City
I don't believe they're trying to make
an allegory for our society in any way
yeah I really don't think so
I think we're talking about Gotham City
I was talking about the Batman universe
why are we so desperate why these
critics so desperate to make this a
political I didn't see it in America
there's a mass shooting or attempted act
of violence by a guy like Arthur
practically every other week wrong I
don't think that I don't think that
they're saying what he did is okay by
the way right and by the way what he did
wasn't just a random act of mass
violence either he didn't just go ran
and a random movie theater and start
shooting people up it was and in most
cases in the first incident where he
murders three people is the result of
them you know in in in and his yeah but
but again it's not random acts of
violence it's just not at least up to
the lead-up of development of his
character so Zack and Ian did you guys
watch it I know Dan hasn't and finally
The Times Magazine I want to read this
one he says he could easily be adopted
as the patron saint of in cells that's
so stupid and you know I feel bad for
Joaquin Phoenix cuz he's ket and the
director the catching [ __ ] like Joaquin
Phoenix is trying to do interviews and
promote the film which by the way is
doing awesome it's gonna make like a
billion dollars worldwide the studio I
read
was nervous to even fund the film they
gave it a super low budget they even
tried to discourage them making it and
now it's made them a billion dollars and
people and interviews are trying to act
like a squawking Phoenix like he walked
out of an interview of think you know
about the stand where they were asking
him about like how does he feel about
does he feel like he's encouraging
violence and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
why he was asked he was worried that the
film might perversely end up inspiring
exactly the no well it's about its
justice like what do you and he walked
out it's not about any people it's about
why is it children with this movie
people are watching so many superhero
movies all the time lately what is
different there's always a villain the
villain is always crazy I think it's
because it's the protagonist the
protagonist in this that is what's
interesting about this people are people
are babies like they can't like they've
been kind their brains have been ruined
by the Marvel movies it's like if the
subject of the movie isn't a good that
really dark version of the x-men
oh yeah the good guys on Amazon it's
called the good guys right the superhero
is so good yeah so great why didn't that
show catch [ __ ] maybe it did I don't
know but I love it we've got a little
bit but I think it flew under the radar
that shows me I can't wait for season
yeah seriously I don't it we're talking
about the Joker the most infamous
criminal of all time I love I personally
love my favorite types of villains are
the ones that they can develop in a way
that makes you sympathetic to them makes
them relatable on a human level because
that's what real villains are they are
relatable they're not just evil for the
sake of being evil
they have motivations and they have
justifications and they don't see
themselves as the villain that's what
good writing is that's what good
character development is things are not
black and white and that's why I love
seeing it from his perspective obviously
he's a violent girl he's a joker [ __ ]
babies like you said that they're just
babies he's
the patron saint of insults he never
talked about anything like that he was
he was a total um he was a total uh
anarchist because at the end he goes uh
do you support the the protest and the
rights and what's going on politically
because I don't care about any of that
I'm just here you know what I mean
mmm-hmm he's not political and what
you're saying he's a nihilist poison
he's a nihilist he's an anarchist
exactly there you go
what did you what did you think in and
Zach I thought it was one of the
greatest movies I've ever seen if I was
like Silence of the Lambs
I enjoyed that film I did too with the
music and it was just it was amazing I
agree I thought it was great
I I was fully satisfied by the
conclusion of that film it was just it
took components from different films and
it just made it I don't know it was it
was so good also it's it's so cool that
you can take someone like the Joker and
make a somewhat serious yeah a a cinema
cinema from it yeah I thought Joaquin
Phoenix did an amazing job you know what
I thought I loved it you know you know
what I'd love to see is um this be the
beginning of a Batman series with what
yeah Enoch says the Joker that could be
cool I would love that out though
unfortunately oh I want that so bad I
think he he views himself as too serious
of walking of an understood to do but I
wonder if there's a way to continue the
series in the same art artful way I mean
I think that that certainly be better
than the [ __ ] other DC movies that me
Yes Man of Steel and all that garbage
that's all hot garbage me out but in you
you didn't really yes uh yeah I was just
like I was all right I mean I enjoyed it
I'm not like this is silence
Williams greatest movie I've ever seen
but like I mean I had a good time did
you get n subs I don't thinks I mean
he's I don't think it says in say that
they're jumping to that but I think that
they're being extra critical of this
movie and I don't really understand why
because a lot of movies do that yeah
they have anti-heroes so I don't know
yeah I don't I don't I really don't know
why he this I that's what I didn't
understand they're laying could like
this super heavy criticism against this
film that seems like you could say that
about a lot of films and I don't know
why they singled out Joker
specifically it was more of a mental
illness film than any fright - yeah but
I'm trying to think because it's not
again it's not really a man of serious
comment on mental illness either it's a
very exaggerated incredibly wild this
this I mean the guy is really just the
victim of circumstance throughout his
whole life I mean like a minor spoiler
here is that his mom is mentally ill
well maybe I should actually this is
yeah I'm not gonna go where I'm going
but but I don't really see it as a
serious commentary on mental illness
either because then people are gonna
like criticism oh well you're gonna say
that mentally ill people are yeah I
don't see I don't know I I loved it I
don't think they were attempting at
least in some level to get that point
across so with the difficulty of getting
right that heads and things like that in
the program being shut down and all that
stuff so I feel like they were trying
for some sort of commentary there that's
true and you know what I loved about his
costume is it was so simple like there
was I love his clothes
yeah costume was awesome then like at
the end when he don't finally Dawn's
this persona of Joker yeah he just dies
his hair it's a little purple they're
not really purple or green I mean yeah
it's like very realistic he puts on them
paint I love that scene where he's
painting his face and he paints his
donkey yeah
it's great it's great yeah it's just
there wasn't any bells and whistles it
was just to the point and cool roger
ebert calm says as social commentary
joker is prone a pernicious garbage so
there you have it
the critics unanimously hate it yet it's
number fifteen greatest film of all time
on IMDB I mean that'll go down new
movies are always very inflated it'll
stay on that list it'll blow yeah it'll
stay high on that speaking of 15 early
on it will you know it'll drop down
maybe 100 or so but it'll Joker IMDB LSU
or Israel let me ask you did you how
would you compare it to like the Heath
Ledger roll of the joke well it's so
different it's like a whole different
thing like eath Ledger was number 13
right now dan 8.9 very well and that's
what 361 thousand points Heath Ledger's
was I guess I could see Heath Ledger a
continuation of Joaquin Phoenix in a way
because if you kind of skip ahead 15
years from where that movie left off I
can see in some ways that character
being a continuation but the one
criticism I did have of the film is that
the Joker is supposed to be a criminal
mastermind a genius I mean Batman is
like they say the greatest detectives
ever lived Batman isn't a genius he is
an incredibly smart investigator and so
this his portrayal of the Joker was
really not he was not by any means a
mastermind mm-hmm he was not by any
means in my opinion a rival to Batman I
mean the Batman that we know from the
comic books would just absolutely own
this guy but what they do in this film
is that they set this movie about 15
years ahead of when thomas wayne was
murdered and batman watched his parents
die so what i think they're attempting
to do is to give time for
him to develop into well the Joker happy
and and traditionally comes up at the
same time as Batman so Batman comes up
and Joker comes up at the same time look
they're around the city yeah
but what happens in this film is that
the Joker makes his first appearance
when Bruce Wayne is like 10 years old so
it's a different it's a little different
timeline so I I'm I'm supposing that
they're saying that he's somehow going
to be developing and to the Joker that
we know because he has 15 years to kind
of get his crime and cult down but I had
a hard time imagining him as a rival
about it right I had a very hard time
that was my only criticism out of the
film cuz I kept thinking I wish they
would have made him like just have a
little more genius or something because
he is just kind of apathetic just
apathetic
slow just kind of a victim of
circumstance and I don't know the Joker
is definitely not any of those so that's
my review baby cool y'all watch it this
way yeah you definitely gotta I'm
curious what you think about it I'm
PewDiePie banned in China this is pretty
spicy
by the way [ __ ] China China is like the
most sensitive bitch-ass country this
president see how do you say his name Qi
see G it's just X I g-g-gee he's such a
sensitive little [ __ ] he can't handle
being likened to Winnie the Pooh if with
people who said I looked like one of the
pills I was the meanest thing people
said about me I'd be lucky here's some
of the memes that PewDiePie showed they
got him banned throughout all of China
manga anime Netflix adaptations I love
that that's good
oh hi G Jinping lost hair can you help
him find it this is much better than six
is Winnie the Pooh here liberate Hong
Kong the revolution of our time
censored censored censored Zhi ping and
Chinese newspaper it's like a jack 20
the pill Zhi ping and Hong Kong
newspapers going mad on honey Jing Zhi
ping ding how do you say his name Zhi
ping Jie Zhi ping Jie Zhi ping I believe
say that again Zhi Zhi ping but I could
G is G pain in American newspapers I'm
assuming that's like a missing
chromosome China then built the Great
Wall invented gun powered powder trained
martial arts China now scared of winning
the pill so true Hong Kong after 150
years of British rule Hong Kong after 22
years of Chinese rule when South Park
mocks you for censoring media and so you
prove them wrong by censoring them I
agree this whole thing of like over
censoring just makes you look so weak
and pathetic if you're really strong you
shouldn't be like how insecure is this
guy ji ping that you're not allowed to
say he looks like when a the pill which
by the way it's kind of endearing yeah
what's the problem we're doing in the
pool I think he wants to be seen as a
serious guy but I mean dude you do kind
of look like went though yeah I don't
know if this is racist but it but it's
not a bad thing it like whenever food is
kind of cute what do you push but now
that he hates it now it's like the hot
new meme yeah of course yeah he looks is
it racist to say a Chinese person looks
like Charlie Brown what what because he
looks like Charlie Brown but I feel like
you could say that about a lot of eight
of Chinese people look he looks like
Charlie Brown look at Charlie Brown
doesn't really well I guarantee does let
me show you look here's Charlie Brown
and here's his face he literally looks
like Charlie Brown
hello he looks like Charlie Brown are
you kidding me that's Charlie Brown as
an adult not really what can anyone back
me up here Thank You battle yeah right I
can kinda sit thank you not growing a
skin
so anyway pewdiepie basically didn't
even say anything like me like where I'm
going like I totally agree what
democracy I think democracy is so
important to the survival of humanity I
love democracy and freedom and I think
the people of Hong Kong deserved a
maxime for him I think the United States
should support Hong Kong because when
one country's are democratic the whole
world benefits I think that Trump is a
little bitch-ass [ __ ] [ __ ] coward
sorry for not supporting Hong Kong he
literally said China can handle their
own business that's unamerican he needs
to say that Hong Kong [ __ ] or rules
and we will always as is in the
Constitution I mean believe in the
ideals of democracy and human freedom
yes then hit him with the honestly Zack
what are we supposed to do we're not
gonna go to nobody war with China at
least voice support for them yeah okay
you know what I mean don't be a little
coward sure that's fair honestly I mean
you know I'd like to see my president
having a spine and standing up for for
their the ideals of freedom that defines
us as a nation as a people I feel you on
that I just don't know what are they
gonna do I don't know and I just don't
know if it's that specific to Trump I
don't think Obama would have said [ __ ]
either I think I think he did mmm I'll
look it up there wasn't a crash going on
when Obama was president in Hong Kong
regardless tentacle what do you think
George Bush would have said
what do you don't think you would have
said what about Jimmy Carter Jimmy
Carter is a pretty nice guy he might
have said something
oh he's it's about niceness now well I
mean I think you're wrong I think other
presidents would have said something
because Trump said Trump said China
should handle their business right I
mean and that's yeah I mean he's
isolationist he's always been like yeah
other countries your problem kind of
thing is his attitude so sorry and well
I disagree I feel you Dan
I'm agreeing with you that we should be
supporting the pro-democracy how much no
I'm just I'm just also on a pragmatic
level what it what is it what are we
supposed to do we're gonna invade China
invade China what are you exactly of
course we're not gonna do that so what
like you should I think it's important
to say it to say yes and and to be also
a frank oh I'd like to see America maybe
even giving a to Hong Kong support
diplomatically regulation aliy I think
that we have to take a stand against
China is just the most it's just scary
the government there it's good it's it's
terrifying and if you have the option
between China and Hong Kong as a player
on the world stage for the betterment of
humanity Hong Kong is is uh is good for
the world these are these are people to
believe in freedom they are productive
they're powerful they're educated these
are group this is a great place Hong
Kong is like a beacon to the world dan I
do think the United States should be
supporting them in any way we can short
of yes invading China dan went dropping
nukes on China honestly honestly
honestly anyway I do think that I would
like to anyway whatever he didn't say
anything like that PewDiePie he didn't
say anything close to that but yet he
was banned in China we're about to be -
by the way I don't they care about us
was there I don't that PewDiePie swag
yeah what does it even mean cuz isn't
like YouTube and Google is alright yeah
that's what I wonder not even so what
they did is basically like China's
version of Google and they have their
own version of YouTube so now PewDiePie
is just banned off all those like they
scrub the Internet of his name like you
there's just no mention of them anymore
he doesn't exist over there incidentally
that's what they used to do in 1984 they
would erase people from memory down the
memory hole and people would act like
they'd never heard of him before so now
everyone China's gotta be like oh yeah
we never heard of PewDiePie let's see
they had a picture someone had a picture
of what happens when you search for it
here oh yeah PewDiePie joke that China
took copyright of PewDiePie in 2017
without him being able to stop them look
at this copyright this is so China we
deal with this [ __ ]
actually we're dealing with some [ __ ]
like this right now look at this you see
how it's written PewDiePie they make
wedding dresses clothing gloves and
wedding dress isn't that amazing yeah
there's somebody trying to do that [ __ ]
to us in China right now that we're
trying to deal with but trying to kind
of give him a favor in a way cuz they
probably are out of business self
oh this was awesome look at this someone
made a gif of his face transforming in
the winning of the pill and it's really
good yeah I mean I would be I would be
honored to be blocked in China too I
don't you know oh yeah this other DJ's
EDD he do you know what happened to said
he had a tour plan for China he liked a
South Park man did we talk about it damn
we talked about this I think it happened
afterwards yeah
South Park made a whole episode about
banned in China and they got banned in
China and then this DJ Zedd who was the
plan to tour in China liked one tweet
from South Park and the and they banned
him
dude like how many people in China are
sitting in the Ministry of Truth just
monitoring Twitter do you know what I'm
saying like that's a lot of manpower
just to look at SEDs of likes that's a
deep cut that's not even a pulse that's
a like here's what happens when you
search PewDiePie and SHINee he like this
is it just says 404 Oh
error 404 interesting I guess I'm a
certain website although some people say
that it wasn't blocked who knows being
reported more widely now this whole
incident so I think it is it was
probably getting more articles coming
out today about it
it probably just took time to really
scrub the Internet of them you know
mm-hmm I mean I would be honored to join
that list but I don't think they care
about the little old age 3 podcast but I
trust me I would love to be banned that
would just only validate my my opinion
that this is the most important not only
the best but the most important show in
the world
I support Hong Kong and I think the US
government should more support Hong Kong
this is all pretty new to me this whole
China versus Hong Kong situation it's
pretty it's pretty what so Hong Kong was
ruled by the British after when to the
bridge take a 12 Hong Kong Oh early
1800s I want to say had the point the
height of their empire that's crazy man
they just should have lost a nice juicy
piece of China Loney ilysm baby why not
mm-hmm so anyway they had freedom and
basically all the rights and ideals of
Western society and they negotiated with
China to give back Hong Kong to China
like 20 years ago and so in that deal
they made an agreement that China they
would have an autonomous government and
that they would still enjoy the certain
freedoms that they've enjoyed for the
past hundreds of years under British
rule like for a time it's actually part
of that agreement was in I want to say
20
46 in the 2040s China is supposed to
fully take over Hong Kong like that's
still in the cards for them really they
would just sell them out like that just
a full it's all you China yeah what is
what are the British care so this is
about all this well the British
obviously cared to negotiate some terms
I mean you know what motivation of the
British have to give it back to China
anyway their empire was crumbling and
they didn't couldn't sustain it anymore
well regardless this whole protest
started over a new law that China
mainland China could act what's the word
god dead what annex no nope that you
could uh when you take a criminal from
Oh X Trudeau after you can extradite
people from Hong Kong to mainland China
right and they and I think they were
afraid that that would be used to go in
and arrest you know with the centers
yeah yeah so it's the whole thing man
but I just don't got a support freedom
and democracy where it is Hong Kong is
trying to separate themselves yeah
that's what they're it started as this
but now it's turned into something much
bigger there's a movement to it and it's
it's complicated not everybody there
wants that a lot of people obviously do
that's why there's violent clashes and
everything but you know there's aspects
of society there that are more friendly
to China and you know just like any
place there's a variety of opinions and
so well there's obviously therein aliens
appear like they local yes and there's a
huge nesting there's a huge clashes of
of Chinese or Hong Kong police I guess
who are backed by China right and the
more violent it gets the more people are
getting crazy and China is working
feverishly to censor people talking
about it as we talked about last week so
yeah I mean I didn't know what's gonna
happen there because China is pretty
crazy they just they just straight up
right
I don't think they have a problem just
with outright violence so yeah we'll see
yep it's a powder keg it's a scary
situation but anyway congratulations to
pewdiepie from being banned in China I
command him and I hope follow suit oh
here's the main story of today you guys
probably seen influencers celebrities
just giving out their phone number and
saying hey guys I'm bored give me a call
and I'll text you back and you may have
thought yourself that's strange
yeah why are all these celebrities
giving out their phone number all the
sudden even site on length Twitter news
I don't know who was the celebrity I
wasn't really paying attention but they
it said like whatever celebrity X really
wants you to call his personal number
what that was trendy
yeah stupid well when I first saw it I
was like oh it's just some weird thing
they're into I first saw ninja do it but
then I started seeing all kinds of
people doing this and I was like there's
something going on here well it turns
out there is a big company behind all
this called
community it's basically just an ad
agency that allows influencers to text
promotions and exclusive offers to their
people who text them
so you're basically when you text them
you're enrolling yourself to get spammed
by this but you're not talking to them
at all
also obviously that's not the real
number even though everyone is like
presenting it like yeah okay this is
creator early
you're gonna call my number literally
not well stay tuned because I have a
collection of all these celebrities what
they say about it and it's just it's so
disingenuous because they all pitch you
like this is totally insane that I'm
doing this but here's my number it's
like [ __ ] you it even says in the small
small print it's like this number was
given to them by community
they didn't they didn't even make the
number it's literally just an ad agency
that you're opting and for these
celebrities to spam you will [ __ ]
directly to your phone and even worse
you're giving community your phone
number to spam they're selling it
they're scraping date uh guess what you
textin injured they're like ooh again
these people are into games and they opt
it in now now that divisions gonna send
them promotions by text yeah I can't
imagine a worse thing to get on my phone
like I get spam everywhere I get spammed
halls now I'm getting I'm getting spam
texts it's pretty awful it's awful and
they're so dishonest that's the part
that really ticks me off is that none of
these guys are up front about it let me
let me continue on community is a
marketing company the Ashton Kutcher is
heavily invested in they are polygons
dug into their Terms of Service one
section reads additionally you
understand that a message sent sent by a
client may appear to come from a
celebrity or other famous individuals or
influencers but may actually be sent to
on his or her behalf by public relations
or other social media representatives
yeah you mean every single one the terms
of use go on to say that the messages
aren't even private so if you text this
number they own whatever you said by the
way but that the interactions are purely
intended as promotions or advertising
the phone numbers are also provided by
community so no you cannot call up ninja
and ask what he's doing for Thanksgiving
you understand and acknowledge that
conversations using the service are not
private conversations with clients but
are intended as messages sent an
interaction solely for purpose of
promoting and/or advertising the client
and the clients products and services
additionally someone on reddit
speculates that they are likely farming
people's numbers for later sales a list
of active phone numbers can be sold for
a good price they said a list of active
phone numbers are already vetted to
allow a certain type of fashion or
lifestyle based on influencer is a lot
more pricey a lot of the clothing lines
would rather want the phone number of
people who follow the influencer as
opposed to just a random list of phone
numbers to cold-call I mean a phone
number lead that's a valuable thing yes
our hot leads these are hot as it gets
you know they could cell phone number a
hot phone number lead for like $5 a
piece or something like dollars on the
spot that's when you add that up man
that's crazy money so all these big
influences I think are just getting a
fat check
like if you had an interest profile it
just says text me and it's got his phone
number in it okay in July TechCrunch
reported on community formerly known as
shimmer weird name so I wonder if there
is earlier because it sounds like she
mole mmm what does she more mean it's
like a reservation or something
I wouldn't be surprised as realize are
all buying this [ __ ] apps yeah shitty
idea not shitty but I mean like not
shitty but like they're good at take the
getting and making money they're good at
I like how do I say predatory yes come
on accept it mmm-hmm all right you know
I'm right it's all bad not all bad it's
great that was great
turns out community is the new name of
shimmer which launched in 2014 to
connect social media celebrities with
their fans according to TechCrunch a
shimmer was meant to be a reddit like
mobile app where users could create and
upload content about their favorite
youtubers or influencers that is until a
pivot to direct message
in 2018 attracted the support of
Hollywood talent manager guy actuary and
the sound Ventures investment partner
Ashton Kutcher who jumped on board to
relaunch Schumer now known as community
the Santa Monica based company has
raised nearly thirty five million
dollars in the form of two convertible
notes following a recapitalization that
occurred a long sighs its rebranding
earlier this year investors including
the Sony Innovation Fund have valued the
text marketing platform at upwards of
200 million how can these tech companies
are I don't believe that when someone
buys them for 200 million I don't think
that I don't see it
this [ __ ] is weird dude I don't see this
going anywhere and they they're too
aggressive with it like here's my
favorite part here's all the influencers
being paid to produce first let's start
with that manager that you mentioned his
name is really there you go oh that's
funny I looked up the actual shimmer
company though the founders are not
Israeli so I mean it sounds like they
got some Israeli letters but yeah yeah
it's probably not I take back everything
I said not really
Ashton Kutcher so he's the first of this
he says just text me it's easier and he
gives out his phone number
Wow incredible he's texting with his
fans not you're texting into a fake
number that is part of this company
community to scrape your data Asha will
never talk to you he only wants to spam
you [ __ ] there's no disclosure there's
no honesty at all they just they all I
mean he may respond to like a few or
maybe they even made together like a
premade response that the name boss they
do ever'one premade response you know
but sure he responds to a few in the
first hour this has a gimmick so they
can like record it and use it as media
yeah or just so he's not like outright
lying
but again the it's just totally
misleading
it's just so weird cuz they got like
legit people as they just are doin him
he's like I feel like it's just a couple
managers who they talked into doing this
we gave him a fat [ __ ] check to
promote it and and it sounds fine you're
like hey you you just have people text
you but the thing is they all kind of
following the same script of like just
text me isn't that so crazy I'm giving
you my number this is what you get when
you text them Ashton here this is an
auto text to let you know I got your
message
the rest will be from me click the link
so I can respond to you I likely can't
respond to everything but I'll try to be
in touch dream bigger shut the [ __ ] up
you'll never be in touch
is that so scum easier and bigger so
here you click the link and opt in I
love this the whole thing seems so
spamming click the link so I can respond
to you I likely can't respond to
everything but I'll try to be in touch
hey Ashton what's going on buddy I'll
try to get in touch stupid so here we go
ninja I have to say ninja to me was a
huge offender I mean look at this
announcement video first of all he texts
but yeah I think I don't want to be too
harsh on everyone because they got like
you have a list here Paul McCartney and
he gets a pass but I'll talk about that
when I come home work hard but you'll
say you'll see he's you could easily
tell he's not involved at all
it's just some manager who signed him up
for this [ __ ] but like look how ninja
pitches this he tweets he tweets his
number 3 1 2 5 a a 4 4 6 8 4 yes this is
my number yes I will receive each and
every text I'll try to reply to as many
as possible this is gonna be fun long
term keep texting me and it has a lot of
likes because people are like oh that's
crazy there's a first time I saw it like
I don't know if there's just something
for a stream that's supposed to be fun
here is how he describes it hunger bond
and this is definitely it some giving
you guys my number you ready it is three
one two five eight four four six eight
four send me a text message right now
there's gonna be a link that's gonna
follow fill it out so I have your
information and I'm gonna be able to
contact you guys text you guys
personally send you guys awesome videos
messages behind the scenes of whatever
event that my beautiful wife Jess and I
are at or even freaking cute adorable
pictures of our little puppies who are
just laying on the couch right now
alright send a text to that number and
also I'll be texting a couple people
that personally asking for your guys for
net gamer tags and we're gonna hit up
some Vic Roy's later on in the week
alright guys so remember it is three one
two the cruel five four four six eight
boards Roy Roy owls bro consoling what
how it starts it for bond and this is
definitely if some giving you guys my
number your anything hunger bond and
this is definitely it some giving you
guys my number you ready you ready it is
three one two are you ready to let me
rip this em they all play it up like
this is that bit this is my real number
are you ready you're not gonna believe
this thing are you it's like dude it's
just and paid advertisement it's stupid
it's stupid and all of his fans are
probably because they don't even know
about they're like this is a whole brand
new gimmick and everyone's like he
probably got so many texts you know not
knowing that they were not knowing what
they were getting themselves into so
that's a ninja Lele pons I mean well
obviously you know this one's actually
not that bad it's just some stupid
Instagram pill text on my new number
text me on my new number I would love to
chat with you guys and I get to know you
better
if you can't text me it's cuz it still
doesn't work outside of the United
States but still put your info so when
it works in other places I could text
you and let you know I would love to get
to know you better
what did they expect to do with this day
influencers because they're like still
put in your info so message you know
what I think it is it's just to promote
their stuff yeah
you can just it's like a posting on
Twitter you post memes you post
announcements yeah so it goes to your
phone
but the truth is that they don't they
don't say that first of all she goes I
would like to chat and get to know you
better I just want to lay in bed at
night late and I add text with my
favorite fan yeah the best friends
basically you're you're like signing up
for a mailing and mailing newsletter you
know to your phone that's your phone but
but yeah but even beyond that is that
this company community is harvesting
numbers to sell the third parties that's
speculation no not speculation that yes
it is wait isn't that in the fine print
I mean it says in the fine print yes it
says in the fine print that they can
share your data with third parties so
it's it's here's the what I have it I
have a direction but we don't actually
know that 100 it says a list of active
phone numbers can be okay the way Oldham
says you grant community a worldwide
perpetual license to host copy transmit
and display your data as necessary for
community to provide the service in
accordance with these terms you also
grant to community a royalty-free
perpetual worldwide transferable
sublicense sub licensable license to
transfer your data to third-party
services from service providers used by
community and providing the service that
sounds like wow I mean I'm not an expert
in terms of service so they always agree
with that I agree with you I do think we
should say based on this statement they
say you also grant to community a
royalty-free perpetual worldwide
transferable the sub license to license
today it's transferable that means they
could sell it
what gives having to being I'm just I'm
getting late in the show baby
type if you're watching at this hour
type in did a mayonnaise gag great job
Ian on the mayonnaise gag of your hand
great job no say this sorry say this I
like that
what do you you have any other ideas not
that funny type Ashton Kutcher say
Ashton Kutcher is a big ass ding-dong
dude Ashton Kutcher can lick my salty
smelly anyway they're selling your [ __ ]
come on who you kidding
who are you kidding they're selling your
[ __ ] allegedly possibly possibly yeah
it's probably it's a comedy show it's
all comedies a parody 30 parody it's a
parody come on oh yeah get in this isn't
a new show this is a parody show and
they're selling your data for sure a
thousand percent I guarantee you they're
selling your [ __ ] data buzz but two
Pringles okay you know just all used to
also gave text from Pringles and that's
what it's gonna be like hey did you hear
about our new Pringles flavoured a talk
of flavor uh-oh dude it's like ninja
send you an image of him with the
Pringles taco flavor ah dude did you
hear about Pringles new taco flavor oh
dude it's not Will Smith did you hear
about new ninja flavored Mountain Dew
dude it could be some big Roy's later
the only thing I'm pissed about is why
didn't these [ __ ] come to me I
would have sold out all you [ __ ] or
like I don't know like only imagine they
got a lot of money I would have told you
guys down the goddamn River oh yeah
they're like half a million bucks so all
your fans out I'd be like hey guys
huge crazy announcement here's my real
number text me when you text it is only
gonna instant reply yeah yeah just an
auto-reply thing
my text a few of them text no you did
yeah that what happened the screenshot
that he put up earlier the Ashton
Kutcher won them did anything follow
well they sent you a link and it takes
you to a page where they want your email
your phone number and an optic yeah I
didn't necessarily want spam from Ashton
cookies should be like did you hear
about the new perennial when I hear
about what he ate for I caught some sick
Vick Roy's with ninja sometimes maybe
you'll hit me up a couple you I'm gonna
be hit some VicRoads with and you guys
hear about the new Pringles oh ok if she
has epic new chicken tenders ok did he
did it
so why doe again I'm giving Paul
McCartney path why look it find out
Paul's phone number and a new Q&A from
Japan it's like he's not even able yeah
it's obvious that he didn't even write
this all doesn't any nope I think you
and a with Paul McCartney let's see what
they say I'm not gonna take it up all
above criticism here no but I'm saying
he's clearly not involved like some
stupid manager was like they're gonna
pay a million bucks in your number
see even then it dude what is Paul
McCartney's net worth pedo I agree I
agree but again it's just next is gonna
start doing cameo what I'm saying is yet
Paul McCartney cameo for 25 bucks a
button here and I wanted to wish you a
happy birthday Thomas is a little jingle
for you net worth 1.2 billion probably
feels forever
happy birthday Thomas that's a John song
come on you know this it's a Beatles
song get the [ __ ] out
we're back in the year honestly honestly
take feelings that I don't even think
this but just to play
one second thank you for correcting me
like that I love when you correct me the
thing is that an engine knows what he's
doing okay when he puts out a video
saying Oh God about to do it are you
ready
this is so crazy Paul McCartney's like
I'm old bro like his tweet didn't even
wasn't even written from him you know
what I'm saying it's like he doesn't
even manage it on Twitter look he got
500 likes that's Paul McCartney like the
most famous person that's ever lived got
500 like I disagree I love that
Photoshop
what what are you disagreeing with Zak
its Paul McCartney like why who would
sell him out like this yeah he's gotta
be shitty manager that happens all the
time I'm giving him a pass I have to
Diddy however you guys gonna love this
but nature is a friend of the show it
was a show he was on the show but just
isn't on the show you don't you're just
immune people gonna say a backstab ninja
team Starwood he's gonna do a whole
one-hour special honestly quite star
game star the clown star okay let's see
what PP looking for them DPP he goes
well look how did he phrases it I
shouldn't do this but text me I
shouldn't do this y'all all right Eddie
yo check this out so I'm sitting in I'm
thinking I'm like you know I'm about to
go into this nature just like yeah you
know I'm gonna be doing a lot of
positive things you know a lot of
disruptive things a lot of things I
really don't want everybody like
everybody to know about so like
everybody knows about everything you
know I want a deeper connection 8 with
my fans so I came up with this out there
I was gonna get a special phone number
and I was gonna be able to give it to my
family my fans everybody does that my
family image that I'm about you know
sitting there movement you know bad boy
you
black excellence entrepreneurial ISM
getting money vibration in about block
inspiration like that fun one is owning
this phone and also on top that I almost
want to be able to be in communication
with charge so when you hear when I'm in
your city
I'll be able to hit you directly and I
think that all hiring manager yeah I
know you're right 741 full no way that
number X that number tell me what it
says Dan you know I'm actually calling
Ashton Savoy oh you're calling for real
and what happens if you call it
obviously know what's ringing oh good
wait is that really your phone that I'm
hearing yeah
come on speaker great
that said who leaves voice messages just
text me in the knee hung up on me [ __ ]
you Ashton yeah I wonder what so so text
Diddy would you don't want to I'm
curious what his message
it was so young said to sound so I'm
nine one seven seven four six one four
four four he probably gets like $10 per
sign up we're making did deal I'm just
saying do you not know who I am why have
I not been approached to sell out my
fans for fur like I mean we don't have a
manager you think yeah I think they'll
have the same manager come on I need
some of that money I want to sell you
out you are all data you are almost
worth about five dollars to me there we
go an auto-reply its Diddy thanks for
texting
who's this be sure to be sure to click
the link and add your contact so you
hear it from me first everything else
will be from here say for me direct say
it's you got a praying emoji it's just
it's the same as everything it just it
all takes you to the same community sign
up page yeah I wonder if they're getting
paid per sign up though because they're
all like laying it on so thick it's all
like bro this is the craziest thing this
is so exclusive Ram bigger I'm gonna
change my mind so you better text me
quick I think they're getting paid CPA
dude well Ashton is definitely invested
right again Ashton is invested heavily
in this company it doesn't disclose that
seems very questionable to me well I
don't think that it's a secret how well
do is people following him they don't
know in this really not a secret but
yeah if you don't disclosing and right
seems like a conflict of interest
marshmallow this one really is annoying
too
I'm King at it thank you you guys are
quick thank you here's a marshmallow who
by the way it doesn't even talk I mean
dude so this is his phone number it's in
the title it's in the description this
is what's gonna happen if you text
marshmallow you guys this Chris Rock
calls in I was like four oh these guys
pockets are deep as [ __ ] Chris Rock
grace rock dummy a joke ever he goes hey
marshmallow you ever get in touch with
Lucky Charms cuz you're a marshmallow
whoa really
I was like Chris Rock bro you're ready
to do man you don't need to do this have
you I thought about working with pop
rocks Chris epic marshmallow epic
[ __ ] content I want to flip this
goddamn came up are you teach though no
I'm Shawn Mendes and Will Ferrell look
at all the phone conversations and
genuine and real conversations I still
like by the way hey Liam its real by the
way but what did i do what did i do what
did i say what happened yeah whatever TI
Tiesto [ __ ] that guy I don't know
marshmallow these are totally cool and
random conversations that you can have
with me if you text my number I get a
CPA I get a I get paid per acquisition
yeah you could text me Oh Chris Rock
states didn't me next marshmallow
505 Dan no I'm working on it he doesn't
know I'm not over it whoa you just got
that I'm over it every time you say I'm
over it every everybody over Rosie oh
I'm not over it I'm into it I'm a
lobbyist love it
I'm loving everybody love
we're all right how long we're almost
gone
we've been going for a long time you
know I think I might have an interest
real number in my phone maybe since he's
so cool all I was giving the wrong
number you guys here's his real no wait
yeah whatever
and then there's Jake Paul of course who
would never as we know based on the and
I want everybody dude you're right ward
on this Drive text me I'm gonna be
replying to as many people are you it
you stupid is that it wait actually text
that let me see if that's a 3-1 Oh
number that might actually I want before
I [ __ ] on him I'm where do you think
it's his real number oh no here no a
litt there's what he got look at what's
his number I have a I have a picture of
it here
hail it I got you save now my lawyers
wanted me to tell you that free a
message frequency will vary your what's
your carrier's message and data rates
may apply reply helped wait you got it
yo its Jake let's text fam make sure you
click the link that I sent you and add
yourself to my phone so I can respond to
you did he really put a disclaimer in
the text one else to death okay whatever
you know Jake calls in so there you have
it that's the epic thing that
everybody's doing so text me I want in
on this money I want everybody's phone
number if I make $5 per phone number and
at least a hundred thousand of you
[ __ ] sign up yeah was worth if I
could get a hundred thousand of you
[ __ ] to sign up that's half a
million bucks Wow
let's go where do you at Oh were you at
community hooked me up with that [ __ ]
I want to sell out every $5 Brad alright
what else we got Trisha on x-factor who
cares
Trisha responded to me a [ __ ] she said
hdhd slut-shame to me whatever you don't
we'd actually don't need to watch it she
accepted my apology which I thought was
quite funny
I heard the big question is she coming
Friday she says yes
Trish is saying she's coming Friday but
I suspect a troll did anyone pay her a
million dollars
I told that will not happen and she
accepted my apology mom Trish would be
so epic if you trolled us by not coming
that'd be so [ __ ] cool out of you
again you've been skating with her what
what's the status
I emailed her I mean we have been in
touch and you called her Beach whale and
stuff and then she's mad and alright
you're saying a wild oh yeah right I
never said she was a beached whale she
thinks they're putting words in my mouth
down I said it looks like she just
watched up on the beach
that's not didn't she say that you said
you said I called her a beached whale
the point being I am yeah she has not
responded to me as of yet oh I will let
you know if that changes I am yes do you
want to come on Friday she said yes but
you did it with a wink face so I said I
feel like you're telling me you're not
gonna show up she said no I'm gonna show
up for sure I said okay so right back
Daniel set up accommodations she has yet
to write back down so that's that takes
us up to the present so we'll see we'll
see I don't know how that one's gonna go
I'm freezing and she's so that's that or
no no we moved you guys we moved to a
new house cool
tell your friends tell everybody you
know that we're no longer at our other
address
we don't live there anymore if you
search my name
ethan klein address that address is
wrong no the one that's at the top of
google that you can find easily it's not
my dress anymore got it
there was just a lot of shenanigans
going on because my dress became public
because white pages is a [ __ ] these
guys are like mafia shakedown they like
post your dress that they automatically
take from public filings it's queer
because it never happened on our old
address they never did that to me but at
our last address what happened before
anywhere yeah
even in new york but we were just
renting there but anyway wasn't like a
month of buying our last house
it's showed up if you just type ii think
line address it was right there and
there was just a lot of shenanigans you
can use your imagination and so we
wanted to move and we did Tata should
not say more seriously with that people
are one you can just say at that point
that we already like well among other
things we kept getting swatted by people
which first of all the first time it
happened was terrible enough because the
police show up with their guns drawn
there's like multiple helicopters with
their lights on the house and then they
left our get the police left our gate
open and shredder got out it was it was
awful it was traumatizing it was
absolutely awful but we thought okay
let's see if it were happening once the
police knew that we had a special
location so they didn't need to respond
with such force so once that it started
happening again they still arrive with
the
copters and the gun is strong I mean
luckily they didn't force entry because
we weren't actually home but they they
were they didn't force entry or anything
like that but the second I mean another
time it happened we were coming back
from New York with Theodore and we
posted an Instagram story on when we
were boarding the plane and I'm pretty
sure these people timed it up for when
we were arriving home with Theodore
mm-hmm to put him in our home two hours
before we got home there was a ton of
traffic so we were very late to get back
to the house yeah and well I just wanted
to the people I didn't want to talk
about except one I didn't want to give
them the satisfaction and I didn't want
to give it any attention or
encouragement but I will say to the
people who think they're geniuses that
calling and a swatting on skype or VPN
or whatever that there is an FBI case
opened that we have gone all the way up
the chain and that you will [ __ ] go
to jail dude we're not only wasting
police time but for attempted murder
like bro do you remember I could do
seriously consider that attempted murder
and by the way do you remember senators
do you remember earlier in the year when
somebody died that way they caught that
idiot and like a day do you think the
FBI can't track your [ __ ] down you are
such an idiot bro like you are gonna go
to jail dude and it's so epic that
you're gonna go to jail and like I was
uh was close to here he was in Glendale
oh guy that did it and got somebody
killed dude you are going to jail the
guy who called that in ISM jail right
now he's in jail harder so do all the
geniuses the thing that's a good idea I
mean there can't be many of them that's
like it's real bottle on the barrel [ __ ]
you're gonna you are gonna go to jail I
guarantee it's only a matter of the time
before you go to prison bro the same
thing that happened at the genius
hackers who reverse engineer my phone
number bro he is
we police called me up and said one of
the guys is Israeli come file a police
report and guess what those guys all
went to prison bro the FBI arrested on
all these little kids think they're so
genius because they call them skyping
VPNs and virtual servers I just wonder
if these kids think that it's just like
just a prank just say bro I don't think
do they understand that someone could
die and they are trying to get something
to that it's that the things that they
tell the police to respond is there are
certain things you need to tell the
police to make them respond so I'm not
gonna repeat what they said because it's
awful to even repeat it it really is
just it's just really a graphic horrible
[ __ ] like the worst thing you can think
of involving whatever everything and so
yeah they know what they're doing
they're telling the police the most
heinous [ __ ] you can imagine to get them
to respond a full force and they're
going to [ __ ] prison bro you should
be looking over your shoulder
perpetually because like the hackers
that thought they were untouchable
we're flaunting it those guys got
arrested by the FBI and even the one in
Israel who's doing it from overseas got
arrested by the [ __ ] Israeli police
too dude
the police called me up I was chilling
at a museum with the illest family we
just came to visit my family they caught
us they're like hey I see that your
son-in-law and daughter are in Israel
can I talk to him Merlin why the Israeli
police got on the phone with me too like
hey can you come sign up a police report
cuz that hacking that happen we tracked
him down he's Israeli
he's your file a police report so we can
go arrest him I was like great
they got all your conversations dude
they showed me like conversation the
police showed me Skype conversations
they were having you guys and if
something happened to shredder the first
time shredder got out and we like we
heard that they were at our house we
weren't home but but shredder was home
and we immediately started driving back
and while we were driving back we saw we
were watching the cameras on the
they were just walking around the house
with huge guns out and helicopters and
we saw them leaving the gates open and I
just knew in kitchen I was gonna get out
and then he did and we saw it on camera
and we just saw him walk out and then we
had no idea what happened was we had to
drive like that home for ten minutes
I thought that we will never see him
again because it was late at night he's
a tiny dog there's coyotes you could get
run by a car and a million things but he
was so scared he was just well yeah Alex
and it traumatized him too because of
the police they were walking on the
house for a while with the
walkie-talkies and it was really loud
and now whenever he hears someone on the
phone he's like traumatized from the
noise mm-hmm so it was so horrible that
drive home felt like forever
and thank God one of the police guys
noticed him getting out and they like
walked him back in and closed the gate
so he was fine but if something happened
to him I would just like I don't know
what to say I really don't they
literally know what these people are
thinking they want that they want
shredder to die and to ruin your life
that's why they do it they should go to
jail for life honestly I agree and
they're gonna go to jail they will these
kids think they're so smart I'm telling
you they're all going to jail it's like
a big problem you know the FBI is
literally uh working on that [ __ ] right
now I agree that was it was terrible and
the time will come back from the airport
with Theodore they tried to they tried
to kill her yeah B they tried to
traumatize our baby they had the police
to roll up on us as we were arriving
home and we moved like a week later
we're out of there what are they gonna
say
oh yeah and someone was speaking to
brought up a really good point you know
if shredder was a bigger dog the police
probably would have just killed him
because the he's if he's a big dog
that's confused and it runs out and he
shows any signs of aggression or if
they're not having an aggression just
barking you know yeah barking like if
there's a random strangers in your
backyard with guns and lights and little
walkie-talkies a good watchdog a good
family member is gonna go out and bar
and bark at them and you know police are
authorized to kill your dog at that
point and it's a good thing shredders
just too sweet
the Swedes can be a little sweet little
dog and he walked out to them like I
think I sell from another angle from a
different camera but he just sweet as
could be walked out to them but on the
original camera angle we couldn't see
that the police were still there so we
just saw him walking out of frame I love
shredder he's the he's the best so um
that's why we moved if you want to kill
someone just go do it don't be such a
coward ass [ __ ] I've got a shotgun come
to my house [ __ ] and don't come to my
house but I'm saying if you're gonna do
it that way
let's let's throw down the high noon you
know what I mean let's go dude let's
have a duel at least so I could see your
face if you're gonna attempt to murder
me like a little coward-ass [ __ ] at
least give me a shot at drawing faster
like a cowboy not funny so come to my
house but if you do I have a shotgun by
my bed that's loaded and ready I'm
serious that's the reality of being a
you know it's famous as we are but I
think it really is for youtubers
specifically it's kind of like orange
streamers or
kind of like I think and pull it people
like I think it always happens around
times when I talk about politics too I
think generally speaking it's it's uh I
do think that it's ant people who are
driven by anti-semitism I think it's a
specific kind of right-wing anti-semitic
radical that's why in my gut I think is
doing that those are the people that
hate me that much
you know that's a hunch obviously but
that I just can't see anyone hating me
so much they would try to murder my
family like that
I guess we'll find out soon huh why will
we vote when they go to present now I
was like well then anyway it sucks it's
awful it's terrible it's the worst
feeling in the world and that I mean
that's that's obviously the worst of it
but there was people like sending pizzas
to our house and sending packages there
was weird of stalked out outside our
house across the street in their cars
like following our our housekeeper
following her home I mean there was just
all these weird shenanigans do it it
just wasn't cool so there you have it or
do that people don't be weird I have a
shotgun loaded and I don't want to shoot
you but if you come to me my family I
will write down yeah yeah yes honestly
right either Eli's a handgun I'd be
worried about her the size of the joke
of course you never went Joker pulled it
out that handgun in the in the Batman
without Kim er he pulls out a handgun
it's like it's like super long you're
pulling out his pants and it's like that
long
that's ela
like that you mean to face no it's Joker
which Batman it was the one with Michael
Keaton oh you just said Val Kilmer I did
yeah you did
oh my goodness well of course I meant
Mikey
that's my dad it was the worst Batman
probably probably dollars Batman yeah
George Clooney Oh Val Kilmer what was
the one with Val Kilmer Batman Returns
how come her is not a good Batman he
does it's not very Bruce Wayne ish
George Clooney was the one with Mr
Freeze and [ __ ] though with Arnold love
that is by far
poison ivy yeah with poison ivy and yeah
and mr. freeze I went to rewatch the one
with the penguin Danny DeVito that was
Val kid that was a Michael Keaton Yuki
was the first to write he was like the
most unlikely but loved the coolest
Batman yeah because he's not macho he's
not masculine he's not really cool he's
kind of just like some regular guy but
somehow he pulled it off as Batman so
unlikely I was reading an article they
were very hesitant to use him as Batman
because he just made a movie called mr.
mom which was a comedy and so he's gone
from mr. mom freaking Batman Bruce Wayne
yeah that's why I'm giving a chance to
so they're casting now is Batman the guy
from Twilight which one the hunk from
Twilight Robert Pattinson I'll show you
a picture yes and that first I was like
oh come on but I don't know you got it
maybe maybe it'll be great Robert
Patterson Pattinson yeah whatever
this guy you're getting worse and worse
oh okay I could see that
I mean I'm gonna give him a shot he's
very young for the role of Batman so no
one's like Michael Keaton what what's
his age
oh he's 33 oh wow he's aged that's a
great age for Bruce Wayne actually
that's a perfect age for Bruce Wayne
there you go
[Music]
I'm watching any Batman movie yeah me
too
Batman's my spider-man 2yoon yeah
yeah I love that I agree Christopher
Nolan by far the greatest Batman ever
portrayed on screen I mean but yeah and
you're so quiet I just have a stomach
full of mayonnaise about that gray I'm
going to the bathroom after that No are
you gonna puke or poop I just need to
one word just overrode my switch it's
not gonna both jump it's not gonna be
fun okay
yogurt poop Zach you're gonna throw up
straight mayonnaise Oh Zach you look
like Fred Flintstone you just have the
pattern that fred is on thank you you
guys don't matter
[Laughter]
look at this show Zach it's literally
Fred Flintstone yabba do all right well
let's wrap it up guys Frick well I have
treasures like a three-hour episode but
like yeah oh my god what I guess I had
more energy than I thought I didn't know
as I had that Envy today well this is
the greatest show of all time I did say
that this is the greatest show ever made
I heard that playing on the streets yeah
people are talking mm-hmm
Metacritic gives it a 98% Wow
number one on IMDB critics hated though
critics a to audience mother
Fred Flinstone yes Fred Flinstone okay
well it's about to [ __ ] puke listen
ride a Tricia might be here she might
not who knows we'll see it's a wild cry
i'll prepare just in case she doesn't
show up i'll prepare for two
possibilities what we keep saying friday
it's gonna people are gonna see it
saturday though right oh we're gonna
yeah we're switching up the upload time
yeah we're gonna post this tomorrow
morning on Saturday in the morning we
just I just found that it seems like
it's less stressful for us and actually
it's been a good experience for the
audience to it it seems like people like
the morning upload so okay so Wednesday
and Saturday oh I I have a PSA as well
Oh everybody been loving the suggestions
for sound bites keep that up when you do
it time stamp that [ __ ] please saves so
much time of having to scrub through a
three-hour poem I've spoken first for
Dan and please keep making entry podcast
memes because those are fantastic and we
love them alright so we'll be back on
Friday just shows Ian more like a wrap
it up just will be back on Friday Dan
come on you got the power don't you oh
sorry we were organizing the stuff back
yet it then Ian you put it on you man I
mean I got a puke I got a puke so bad
we'll see you guys on Saturday morning I
guess is what I'm saying but we're gonna
be here in on Friday we're doing it up
for you guys and please text me I don't
have the number yet I need to get that
from community who will reach out but
I'm gonna connect with them I want all
your phone numbers five dollars a pop
and I'm just gonna send you a bunch of
crap so it'll be great thank you guys
for watching we love you we appreciate
you we'll see you in a little couple few
days have a great week keep slamming
shake your tip keep your heads up stay
positive keep slam and give me your
phone number I want to make money off
you and I wish all the best okay have a
great week Brady look that's right all
right guys take care
[Music]
you